there's no time 13 o clock hey you guys
here we are once again for episode 188
yeah
holy crap you guys yeah it's Saturday
yeah we're recording this on Saturday
night most you probably know by now at
least people that you know listen to our
show all the time but we've started
putting up like little daily updates
yeah so we've done so many of those it's
like now I don't know if we're gonna
have side tracks on the regular show I'm
sure we probably still well it's just
that's just daily information keeping
you guys occupied and we're talking
about the apocalypse and it's just you
know I told you I was going to talk you
through the apocalypse I'm talking you
we're not we're not talking about the
apocalypse we're talking about all kind
of different shows Elvis and books and
yeah all kind of cool [ __ ] yeah it's
Saturday and I just saw some stuff
coming from France France is undergoing
the damn apocalypse right now man they
got a lot of sick people there so you
know heart goes out to France yeah well
everybody I guess yeah we're all kind of
in the same boat I think they're 14 days
ahead of us yeah we shall see can't
worry about it I can't really do
anything about it so no just stay at
home just kind of stay home if you can't
distance from other people some people
can't Russ you know cuz of their work or
whatever wash your hands don't touch
your face what she should have been
doing before
I'm just saying everybody's every good I
touched my face all time but I don't
like that
I'm glad anymore but I'm just saying
people should have been like washing
their hands and stuff yeah
before this yeah before I guess but yeah
so this episode is kind of a several
case episode and I think someone
suggested this a while back and I
thought what a good
idea because I can cover like a lot of
cool cases on that this is kind of like
a famous crimes of old Hollywood type of
show so I had five different cases I was
going to talk about it's going to be
William William Desmond Taylor Fatty
Arbuckle Natalie Wood Bob Crane and
George Reeves a gay Superman
yeah so we're gonna talk about those
five so that should be a pretty
entertaining show we'll probably just do
one case at a time it was George Reeves
related to Christopher Reeves
no no just Christopher Reeve was Reeves
okay it didn't have an s already never
Ness all right so they okay yeah it just
happened that they both had ended up
playing Superman yeah
what are the weird things so before we
get into that let's see we have a couple
of shout outs again I think I said this
on one of what you gotta fly yes gonna
fly okay good hopefully yeah so I think
we said this on one of the side track
shows but thank you very much Dominic
for sending us the movies we're in the
middle of the Elvis one right now
watching that with with the crustle in
it and he also sent us Hellraiser which
we'll probably review at some point cuz
that's actually been on those for a long
time but we hadn't got around to it so
thank you very much for that also want
to give a shout out to Hannah who sent
me a PayPal donation and also Jason who
sent me a very large PayPal donation and
requested a t-shirt or a book okay so I
was like I'm probably gonna well I just
got it today is the first time I've
heard of it well yeah because I just got
it today okay that's why it's like you
know what do you expect I can't just
like play shirt out of my butt we gotta
like go buy things closed I got no I
have been on what sighs he wants I have
some some stocks of black shirts oh okay
I didn't know you had a name yeah I got
the guy about 10 or 15 blank ones oh all
right and I can make him well I can make
you one all right yeah well I'll get
what he wants a third one this is 13 on
it I'll ask him like I said I just heard
about today so that's why you're
religious here about it now
I think that's probably all the
shoutouts we have all right because do
you have any other step you weren't
talking about before we open
but look at the kitty what is she doing
she's behind she's crawled out from
behind the damn screen what are you
doing other computer I've never seen him
do that it's just going out like I don't
care you're so weird boogie I was I
can't reach the camera otherwise that
would turn her around yeah all right so
as I said we're doing like famous crimes
of old Hollywood type stuff so the first
one that I want to talk about these are
in roughly chronological order not
exactly but the first one I want to talk
about is the case of William Desmond
Taylor now this was actually a pretty
big deal in the silent era and I had
actually never really heard of it until
I started researching my first faceless
villain book because this happened in
1922 so I kind of gave a summary of it
in there but this is like a really
fascinating case and this case along
with the Fatty Arbuckle case which I
also want to talk about next that was
kind of the thing that was responsible
for the infamous Hays Code and all these
like things where actors and stuff like
that in Hollywood like they had to sign
like moral turpitude clauses and stuff
like that that said that they wouldn't
do anything bad but do anything bad like
they wouldn't do drugs or like commit
adultery or anything like that because
they had to like maintain their image
you know what I mean so this was this
was one of the things that was the start
of that even though it's kind of dumb
because it seems like he'd like the
actor or he was actually an actor and
director William Desmond Taylor didn't
seem like he was into a lot of that
stuff but a lot of the stuff surrounding
the case you know kind of brought a lot
of stuff to the fore because there were
so many [ __ ] suspects for this [ __ ]
and there was all kind of like crazy
[ __ ] going on so now William doesn't in
Taylor he was originally from Ireland I
think he was like he had like an English
mom and an irish dad or something like
that and he was born overseas he was
born like of a kind of a wealthy family
like Lane
the gentry type now interestingly for
some reason I guess there was some kind
of trend which I don't think lasted very
long but we're like the English and
Irish landed gentry would like send
their offspring like once they were
teenagers are like young adults or
whatever they would send them to United
States to become like gentlemen farmers
for whatever reason I don't know like to
toughen him up or something like that so
so he ends up moving to Kansas and was
there for a little while now by this
point he hadn't changed his name yet he
was actually born William Cunningham
Dean Tanner because they had to have
plays big long landed gentry they had
these long hyphenated names and stuff so
he comes over to Kansas he kind of gets
into acting and stuff like that gets
interested in that so then he moves to
New York now while he's in New York he
marries another actress and they have a
kid but then it seemed like he was kind
of known as a little I don't know if he
was an alcoholic but he was kind of like
a heavy drinker he was a party kind of
party guy um you know kind of cheated on
his wife allegedly they said he was kind
of a womanizer so he had been married he
was 36 years old at this point so he was
married and had a young daughter but
then one day he just took off because
you could do that back then so he just
abandoned his wife and daughter and was
like I'm Audi and he took off so his
wife divorced him in 1912 about four
years after he left and for a little
while they don't really know what he was
doing they think that he kind of went
around like in Canada Alaska and stuff
like that he's like panning for gold he
was doing like all kind of weird [ __ ]
like that
China [ __ ] damn live an enjoyable life
I guess yeah he's gonna be kind of like
something out of the American Old West
yeah it's like [ __ ] it I'm gonna go over
the live with the Indians way to go
straight Jeremiah Johnson yeah it might
have been something like yeah so in 1912
though the same year that his wife
finally got a divorce from him because
she figured he wasn't coming back he
turned up in San Francisco and he had
changed his name at this point to
William desmond taylor and he had some
friends there that kind of like got him
established and you know loaned him some
money or whatever and i'm sure he
probably had some from his family as
well because they were kind of wealthy
and starting in the following year he
starts working in the movies and he
apparently does like really well he was
in a lot of movies and he was in a lot
of kind of well-known movies at the time
some of which have been lost which a lot
of movies from the silent era were but
you know he started out as an actor and
i guess he eventually worked his way
into directing and ended up directing
like 49 movies you know i mean so this
was like no and he was actually at the
time in the you know late 1910s early
1920s he was one of the highest-paid if
not the highest-paid directors in
Hollywood he had like a big huge house
he had like a big huge car he was the
Spielberg of his day yeah and it was
like a big huge deal and he worked with
like a lot of you know the luminaries
that people still remember like from
nowadays now he had like a good
reputation around town like everyone
thought he was he was a great guy they
called him the gentleman director you
know even though when he lived in New
York with his first wife he kind of had
a reputation of being a womanizer and
stuff he didn't really have that in
Hollywood most people said he was a real
stand-up guy he wasn't into anything you
know particularly shady or anything like
that so either they're just his buddies
and they're like backing him up or he
just he did that bad thing and then he
went on some kind of spiritual journey
her wherever he went and he decided he
was a bad person he just thought he was
gonna be a better person I don't really
know the funny thing is that well it's
not that funny but so his his first wife
and daughter they didn't know where he
had gone and they actually ended up
going to the movies and seeing him in a
movie like this and being like hey
that's my husband
damn so it's like that so they did find
him that way and he did actually like
come forward and like start like paying
he was using a different name a new name
yeah he had changed his name the weird
thing is that he had a brother well he
had like four or five siblings I think
he had a brother who did the exact same
thing like he went and married somebody
who had a kid and then like one day he
just took off and like didn't tell them
he did a foster after um I think it was
after okay I don't remember I don't
brother told the person after you can
get away with it yeah it's like the back
dam I did it and it was hard to prove
your identity and you can switch it
identity easily yeah so you know you
clearly and there were the federal
government's and the state's really
couldn't reach across straight lines to
do anything and once you left one state
and went into another state you were
home free yeah and we've talked about
that before especially like a lot of
these crimes that happened like a long
time ago you could basically I mean I
don't know I'm sure this if it was
different I don't I don't know what the
legality was about just like changing
your name I don't think he had to do it
legally you just showed you may not have
just showed up in the new state and told
him what your name was yeah and then you
just built on that
but from what I could remember and this
is probably back in the 80s I think you
had to pay like $100 and like you had to
go to like maybe like a notary or
something yeah you had to go to like a
notary and change your name and then you
had to like publish it like so everybody
could see you like you had to publish it
somewhere public like you know like in
the newspapers yeah and in that post-war
era you know the early 1900s even back
in the 17 in the eighteen hundred's for
you people that are maybe a European an
American state was like a country they
were basically sovereign the federal
government in Washington DC was was an
organization kind of like the EU I guess
you would say it was like a super state
but it respected the sovereignty of the
states each one of them kind of had
equal Authority in the Union so the
federal government couldn't do anything
to him yeah and it couldn't do well
that's not a good way the federal
government could do things to them it's
just that a citizen could go from one
state to another and one state couldn't
reach across the other state and really
do anything to that
in that state yeah so you know motorized
bandits like body and Clyde would commit
bank robberies in one state right near
the state line and then jump across the
border into another state and they were
home free they didn't commit that crime
in the new state yeah new state couldn't
even arrest him for it
that guy sorted out later especially
post-war after World War two that's
really kind of when the Union got really
strong to where there was interstate
compacts and stuff yeah couldn't really
let people get away with that [ __ ] for a
long well people would be abusing it I
think it I think it made more sense you
know post-war because there weren't
there wasn't a super super state highway
system there wasn't a bunch of mass
transit going from one state to the next
it was hard to pick up from one state
and run into another state packing
there's dirt roads yeah even if you had
a car it was still dirt roads it took
forever to traverse them so interstate
crime wasn't as common because it was
such a pain yeah interstate travel was
not that common you know it was still
kind of like the horse days ya know and
then you know in the Wild West period
was kind of like the kind of like piracy
on the high seas really it was a similar
situation going across the dam High
Plains was kind of like going across the
ocean if you didn't have a horse you die
kind of like if you didn't have a boat
you die yeah and people stole from each
other out there there wasn't any kind of
clear state there was there was
unclaimed territories so there was no
state rules
it was just like Mad Max land yeah like
the high seas
so the America kind of came from that
and its culture still kind of influenced
by that except for maybe like the New
England states yeah but the rest of the
United States that's that's why the
United States is just buck ass wild you
know that's why out here you can get in
trouble and and they'll deal out some
hellacious punishment to you but it's
still not really tame say compared to
Europe Western Europe
probably no no and then you know you
compared to Japan and Korea man you talk
about tame very tame
people are Loki yeah yeah more people
should do ok I think how you look at it
it's fun because well yeah well it's
more fun for other people who don't have
to put up with their conformist though
they're highly yeah I'm not super into
that I'm you know a man like you
couldn't walk around Japan with with
with the tattooed sleeve like that yeah
you can't even go into the public baths
with that cuz they look at you as a bad
person yeah there's a bad person
ya know that but you're not I mean
conformity you know there's there's I
like things that are kind of like a
mixture yeah yeah I mean well I think
it's too tame he gets too conformist
yeah alright so yeah so like I said this
guy had successfully kind of like you
know abandoned his old life changed his
name everything like that I forgot to
say that he did some military service as
well in World War one and then started
directing when he got back from that now
here's what ended up happening to him so
it's Thursday February 2nd 1922 Williams
had well he was like his kind of
manservant valet type of guy's name was
Harry Peavy and he comes out of the
house Atta Williams bungalow at the
Alvarado Court Apartments in Westlake
Los Angeles and is yelling that William
is dead now he had come to work at
approximately 7:30 that morning and had
seen his boss lying on the floor in the
front room he was lying face-up
initially they thought because they
didn't at first see any blood or nothing
like that so they initially just thought
he'd had a heart attack or stroke or
some like that and it just kind of like
you know died of natural causes he was
in his 40s at this point I think he was
49 when he died now the weird thing
about it is that this is back in the old
days you know what I mean it I've
mentioned this before when we talked
about like older crimes but they will
just like let people walk the [ __ ] in
there and like touch [ __ ] and like just
like hey let me let's check this out and
all this other kind of crap so
apparently you know
he was yelling for everybody in the
neighborhood like the neighbors came
over it's like you know other people on
the street came over to see what was
going on somebody came into the house
and said that they were a doctor and
kind of like gave the body a once-over
and said oh he must have died of a
stomach hemorrhage and then the guy like
the doctor like took off and they never
could find that guy again yeah so yeah
he wasn't a doctor because that wasn't
him
well it's not what William died up there
just more this [ __ ] I was talking about
earlier yeah yeah so later on eventually
somebody thinks to roll the body over at
which point they see a bullet hole in
his back and a little puddle of blood
all right
so doctor couldn't even find a damn
bullet hole yeah I don't think I just I
just think that was some crazy person
that walked in off the street he wanted
to see the dummy he wanted to see the
body
yeah he just wanted to see a dead body
yeah so the cops start going through
William Dean Taylor's pockets now they
found a wallet that had a bunch of cash
in it I think $78 which is over $1000 in
today's money a really nice pocket watch
silver cigarette case and he had like a
really nice like a really expensive like
diamond ring and stuff there's like so
clearly robbery was not the motive
because there was a whole bunch of stuff
that was still there and not taken there
there was however a sum of money
apparently that he had told his
accountant about like the day before and
it was missing out of his accounts but
they never did find out what what
happened to that but nothing was stolen
from the house it didn't look like
anything you know it didn't look like
there was any forced entry or anything
like that now so the first person of
interest was as usual the last person to
have seen him alive now this was a very
dear friend of his who was in a lot of
silent movies her name was Mabel Normand
she was like a comedic actress and she
was actually in a bunch of movies with
Fatty Arbuckle who we'll be talking
about later in the show the two of them
they're not really sure if they were
romantically involved they think that
that perhaps William Taylor was in love
with her but she was like a
commitment-phobe but they did like hang
out a lot and he did have like when he
died they found like a he had like a
locket that had like a picture of her in
it so um you know she kind of had a
crush on him and he kind of had a crush
on her and I don't know if it's not that
it wasn't reciprocated it's just that
maybe she wasn't I don't know I don't
know what it was but they were like
really good friends and they hung out
all the time so apparently she told
police that she had left the house at a
little before 8 o'clock in the evening
they had been hanging out they had been
like drinking this was during
Prohibition so they had been like
drinking liquor
which was technically illegal but they
had had a few drinks he had loaned her a
book and she had left about 7:45 8
o'clock she had a chauffeur
drive her limousine around and she was
seen to get into the limousine they kind
of blew kisses at each other and she
went home now the neighbors also said
that they heard something that sounded
like the old infamous car backfiring at
about I believe 8:45 or 9:00 p.m. so
when he turned up dead of a gunshot
wound obviously everybody thought well
that's probably the time that he was
shot so after they um interviewed Mabel
Normand she was very very upset I mean
obviously because this has been like one
of her best friends and he was dead now
so they did like interrogate her for a
really long time since she was the last
person to have to have seen him before
he died but eventually they you know
kind of they figured well obviously it
couldn't have been her so then they
started looking into some other suspects
and it turned out this this is like a
fascinating case to me because there and
I don't know if this is just like a
testament to the kind of business he was
in because even somebody as reportedly
straight-laced as he was like a nice guy
and every
thing there were so many people that
would have had motive to kill him and
it's kind of like scary you know what I
mean like and the you know the [ __ ] that
came up they're like well this guy did
this then the other and this woman did
this that the other and there was like
all these reasons and I don't even I
can't even like decide I don't think
like who I think did it
I have I don't know I have some kind of
I have some kind of suspicions Oh kind
of things you talk to young people over
you can't tell no no no no that's that's
what I mean he wasn't
that's what's alarming about it all
right so the first suspect that they
looked at was this guy named Edward Sanz
now Edward Sanz had been his like
servant valet guy before Henry Peavey I
think I said Harry Peavy before but it's
Henry Peavy actually so Edward sands had
been his you know former employee now
this guy he had a whole bunch of like
convictions he had forged checks in
William Deane Taylor's name he had taken
his car like when they were all on a
trip in Europe he had taken his car like
out for a joyride or something like that
erected he also had charges for
embezzlement I don't think from him but
maybe for other people he had deserted
from the US Army multiple times multiple
times yeah that means he must have
joined in a different name I think he
did yeah because yeah he had like a
whole bunch of different aliases now he
had been working for William Dean Taylor
for since it's since about I think it
was seven months like before he was
murdered that he got fired because I
guess William D Taylor smile like hey
can you like quit stealing all my [ __ ]
and like doing all this so he fired him
and Sanz apparently had broken into
Taylor's bungalow and stolen some [ __ ]
and they knew it was him because they
found like his shoe prints like across
the bed like he had run across the bed
and like left shoe prints and stuff so
not a master criminal so he was kind of
the first guy that they thought of just
because he had such a long long rap
sheet however he had disappeared and
they could not find him
so they don't know if it was him or not
so the next person they looked at was
the guy who found the body
his current valet cook slash servant
whatever whose name was Henry PV he was
he didn't really have a long rap sheet
although a lot of sources point out that
he had been arrested for like three days
before the murder he had been arrested
for social vagrancy which what the hell
is that I don't even know social
vagrancy you know what that means I mean
I know vagrancy means like being
homeless or social vagrancy must be
something sexual mmm something something
antique that you couldn't get you could
never get convicted for nowadays that's
what I'm saying I don't know kind of a
weird term like being an [ __ ] or
cheating cheating with people's wives
well that would be adultery so what was
so I can't figure could it be a
euphemism for male prostitution possible
but that's kind of like a stretch I
don't really know everything fine like
the mystic fact they go behind the cop
goes behind a damn dumpster and [ __ ]
two dudes jump up off the [ __ ] ground
[ __ ] pulling their pants up and [ __ ]
you can't really catch him for nothing
but you know they were [ __ ] doing a
nasty you go that's a social vagrancy
yeah that sounds something like that
something like that but yeah that's just
my [ __ ] imagination yeah I don't
really know I don't know it's trying to
think I should probably look at that
right but yeah so he had been arrested
for that but that seems less than
relevant in a murder case but whatever
so some people have said that about that
now it's funny because there was this
one reporter this woman I think her name
was flora Belle mirror or something she
was just adamant that Henry PV was the
killer and she thought of the most
horrifyingly hilarious yet kind of
racist way of like proving it because
Henry PV was african-american so she
said that she said that well I know that
black people are afraid of ghosts okay
yeah so she got these
- like compatriots yes [ __ ] sheets on
and then she told Henry PV it's like hey
um can you show me where William Dean
Taylor's grave is yeah oh you know give
you like money or whatever and when they
all went to the cemetery like she had
these like this guy jumps out in a sheet
and says I'm the ghost of Li like I've
you know confess confess the stupid
thing was that the guy she got to be the
ghost yeah had like a real like um like
an accent kind of like a like a I don't
know what kind of like a mobster each
type of accent like from the Chicago or
something like that yeah and Taylor was
British right and he had like a really
like upper crust kind of right so I mean
Henry P V immediately is like what the
Fox you know me and get the [ __ ] out of
my face of that black people are afraid
it goes yeah II learned this [ __ ] from
buckwheat she must have seemed like well
rascal she little rascals God oh well
buckwheat is afraid of ghosts the little
recive therefore all black people must
be afraid of ghosts which means that
they would be fooled by a person and a
sheet coming out from a gravestone that
didn't even talk like the birds there's
gonna be like with the [ __ ] what is
she thinking
but yeah so obviously that's low
expectations like yeah that [ __ ] story
just like correct it was like what the
[ __ ] kind of cockamamie yeah he'll fall
for this yeah yeah so again so I was
talking about a Mabel Normand before and
she got like you know interviewed
extensively because she was the last
person that seen him alive and you know
one of his best friends now even though
they determined that she was very likely
not the killer I've never read any
source that tried to make it so that she
was the killer she didn't have any
motive she didn't have anything like
that however there is something that's
kind of related to her that may have
contributed to his death and the fact
was even though Taylor wasn't into drugs
Mabel Normand most
only was and a lot of you know she kind
of ran with I was watching a documentary
about this earlier she kind of ran with
the Hollywood fast crowd you know what I
mean so then they were all on drugs man
back then it's like you know good old
days like I said yes now if people think
no yeah they were all on drugs and that
cuz they were like they're very easy to
get they were everywhere everybody end
this like I said this was during
Prohibition too so it's like not only
drugs but also yeah and bootleg hooch
yeah the nineteen yeah you know this is
1920s was in 1920 to 1922 yeah people
don't realize that there was another
sexual revolution going on at that time
in the 20s and it was off the chain it
was LGBT it was sucking it was it was
interracial it was everything it was it
was going down back then yeah and from
my understanding based on what people
have written about age wasn't a factor
they were [ __ ] having sex with
underage people it was it was wild yeah
it [ __ ] you would walk away with [ __ ]
you couldn't get away with no time yeah
and they would talk to talk about it
yeah like a little bit later was the
name Errol Flynn mm-hmm Errol Flynn
basically bought like a
fourteen-year-old girl from the fam from
her family and just kept her in the
house he had it down because that was
allowed back then yeah gently yeah he
had he had her in a special room they
had a damn two-way mirror in the ceiling
and all his friends had [ __ ] take
turns going at and they'd watch each
other she there was she was kind of like
I made but like I said but like a sexual
servant to how do you feel about Robin
Hood yeah he was big into coke eject
himself
oh yeah and rage girls and logic yeah
and like I said well there was a lot of
it was very very very very commonplace
and Mabel Normand was very into cocaine
she had been trying to get off it though
and that was one of the things that
William Dean Taylor been trying to help
her with he was trying to help her get
over her addiction now he was so
anti-drug and so adamant about helping
her
get off of the drugs that he came
forward and he was very vocal about
going to like the feds and telling them
that he would help them crack down on
like the people she was getting the
drugs from like the dealers and [ __ ]
like that so the fact that he was so
involved in trying to investigate drug
dealers has also led some people to
speculate that perhaps he was simply you
know there was a hit put out on him for
that very reason now I'm not sure about
that because it doesn't seem and I'll
get into this in a bit but it doesn't
seem like a like a mob style execution
um you know what I mean the way that he
was shot it was a pretty small caliber
weapon but he was like shot in the back
and I'll kind of get into like there was
a weird angle that made them think that
it was you know that the shooter was in
a particular position which a mobster
wouldn't be so uh so I do feel like
there's probably another reason but
that's just another like aspect you know
of his life that might have contributed
to him dying now the weird thing is that
one of his neighbors whose name was
faith Cole McLean she was also an
actress and I believe her husband
Douglas was as well now they were the
ones that said that they had heard the
sound that sounded like a car backfiring
at about 8:00 p.m. and they said she she
said that she looked out the window and
saw someone coming out of Taylor's house
now she said the person was not hurrying
um
you know they didn't look like they were
in any kind of rush or anything like
that she said that the person saw her
like looked at the window and saw her
looking at him and then kind of smiled
at her and then went back inside the
house like he forgot something and then
came out again so they asked they said
well what did this dude look like and
she said he looked like someone that
liked like a movie conception of like a
burglar you know I mean she said he was
like funny-looking like he had a costume
you know what I mean and she didn't get
a good look at his face so she yeah she
said that he looked like uh you know
like a movie burglar somebody dressed up
to be a burglar that's what I'm saying
and she also speculated I'm not sure if
this was like a later attribution to her
if she actually said this in her police
report but she said she said that it
might be a woman dressed up as a man hmm
so there's that whole issue also just
because the person wasn't that tall and
like they were kind of slightly built
and stuff so another thing that happened
to that kind of hampered the
investigation was that and this is not
proven um one they think the cops kind
of like [ __ ] up the investigation like
I said people were like stomping all
over the [ __ ] crime scene and
everything like that they also think
that the guy who was the manager of
Paramount Pictures at the time who had
tailors contract went into the bungalow
before the cops got there and took out a
bunch of stuff like he took out all the
illegal hooch that was in there because
he didn't wanna get any trouble he took
out apparently some love letters
he took out like some women's lingerie
that had been in there anything that
could be seen as like scandalous
apparently the guy from paramount went
in there before the cops got there and
took all that stuff out weird time
because you know general public was
pretty uptight but yeah the elites were
[ __ ] off the chain man
and really that didn't trickle down to
the middle class of the working class
for [ __ ] decades yeah but you can go
back the Hollywood actually contributed
a lot to modern standards of [ __ ]
attractiveness and hygiene you can go
back and go look at photographs of
actresses and actors from the 20s mad
and they have their [ __ ] together looked
yeah yeah I mean you know the average
person I don't think look like that
obviously but that promoted a lot of you
know that promoted people to to raise
their standards yeah you know and one of
the things that ended up kind of going
mainstream over the time was kind
like weird sexuality yeah yeah I mean it
took decades though it took decades but
it started in that era with those people
that's that particular scene and like I
said this murder as well as the Fatty
Arbuckle case I mean that really kind of
like brought into if people didn't know
about it before it dad brought it wrong
he was doing into kind of the mainstream
the public consciousness the
quote/unquote decadence yeah of
Hollywood and like how something should
be done about it
yeah and then you had young real young
rich guys like Howard Hughes of that era
trying to buy his way into that scene
bought RKO Pictures and you know going
out with you know Hollywood starlets and
there were some of the starlets ended up
writing books you know just a few
decades later you know talking about
everything that they did yeah they would
you know they were they weren't shy
about it most of those old days some of
the [ __ ] is like as bad as you know like
the [ __ ] Motley Crue book it's over
yes yeah worse worse I think worse
because sometimes you know I mean like I
said underage people were involved yeah
it's like nowadays we atleast she even
got [ __ ] standards yeah [ __ ] you
would go to jail for they were yeah they
were doing it back and it was like no
big yeah and also because like I said
because it was during Prohibition and so
many of them were like drinking aren't
gonna drop leg liquor and that so that
so it wasn't regulated so it's like they
were drinking they drink pretty much
anything there's no what the hell was in
that [ __ ] yeah they didn't know what was
any of the drugs they didn't know was
that anything they would just take it
yeah they're just like just partying all
the time so like I said there were a lot
more hardcore than yeah lots lots of
homosexuality lots of lesbianism I mean
it's all going on yeah that's what it is
nothing new nothing new no they kind of
saw themselves as kind of being
futuristic and standing outside of
society and it was something kind of
like you know well you know the ancients
did it and they knew what they were
doing and you know we're we're not
normal human beings where the gods yeah
basically as gods are the silver screen
yeah and I imagine that you know in that
air in that era when nobody had any
money except you that's how you fell
well yes they
do whatever you want it yeah they had a
[ __ ] ton of money cars that average
person could only dream of they had it I
mean I think it still happens nowadays
with people that are so rich that they
never really have to interact with us
true evil at all something they do in
the sense that like people that work for
them and stuff but they're so insulated
from normal people's lives that yeah but
I think I think they feel like they can
just do what that whatever the [ __ ] I
think this arrow is the first time you
had celebrities that had that much power
more actors and actresses that had that
yeah because some of these people are
making a [ __ ] ton of money they were
making more money than say European
nobility yeah they were you know they
had more power than them you know yeah
it definitely it seemed like that yes
yeah they're more powerful than
politicians yeah to a certain extent so
you know yeah there was ever been an
interesting time to live it would have
yeah but you know it was little
what's-her-name
she was an actress she was she kind of
exposed a lot of that much later she
mostly did real racy flicks in Germany
and then she did kind of tame ones here
um she had little Bob haircut she came
from the 20s that was a lot of them
Clara Bow No Oh close what was her name
she's a girl I know she wrote she wrote
a book about it and I remember she kind
of had a funny name she did she did
movies she wanted to do bigger and
bigger roles but you know Hollywood
really it was pretty tame so she had to
go to Europe to do [ __ ] cool cuz yeah
in Germany and it was it was silent film
anyway yeah so she didn't have to speak
the language I'm trying to member what
her name was but she was kind of like
the Natalie Portman of the time yeah
bitty thing but she told off you know
she'd marry millionaires and then
[ __ ] divorce him because they were
lame she didn't care about money yes
funny she care about divorcing you this
is how she was like I realized that I
had married a fan you know get out here
you know yeah some of the artists I
remember who it is I'm talking about
but yeah so speaking of Hollywood
starlets now let's get into a couple of
the suspects and I think this is
kind of more where I feel like we're
getting warmer as to like something to
do with like who killed this guy so what
are the suspects that they looked into
was this little lady named Mary miles
Minter now she um at the time that
Taylor died she was 19 years old she had
been in like a whole bunch of movies she
was very beautiful beautiful girl she
was in a shit-ton a movie she played
Cleopatra she put all this other kind of
stuff now she had been a child star um
Taylor was kind of her protege he was
much older than her apparently some of
the love letters that the Paramount guy
allegedly took out of Taylor's house
were from her however everyone that knew
Taylor said that her affections for him
which were apparently um really really
really intense were unrequited
apparently Taylor had said hey you know
I'm old enough to be your dad it's like
have a daughter your age it's creepy
it's like and he was kind of had a thing
for Mabel Normand who was closer to his
age and so all of his friends said that
he had he was nice to her
because they work together and stuff but
he like had refused her sexual advances
also she had some mental issues you know
what I mean so they did find love
letters from her and they found some
lingerie that was hers but apparently
she had she would sometimes turn up at
his house
like in her lingerie and be like love me
and he'd be like yes you need to go so
apparently it was kind of like that
however the papers because they found
out about the love letters they
published all that [ __ ] and said oh
these two must been [ __ ] even though
Taylor's friends all said no that wasn't
what was going on it's like she just
kept bugging him and he was getting
annoyed about it so some people now the
fact that that this all came out about
her that kind of like damaged her career
because she had kind of made a career to
playing these kind of wholesome like I
said she started as a child star she was
only about 19 at this time and she was
kind of like a wholesome kind of it girl
type of you know actress and the fact
that she had written these steamy
letters to like this much older man
you know caused a lot of her like her
career to be damaged so some people have
speculated that because remember how I
said that the neighbor saw this person
coming out of Taylor's house that looked
like they were wearing like a burglar
type costume and thought that it might
be a woman dressed as a man so some
people have speculated that Mary miles
Minter was actually the killer that she
actually didn't go to the house
intending to kill Taylor but that she
went there to like again profess her
love for him maybe she had like worn
some lingerie under a trench coat or
something it had been like hey I love
you and all this other kind of stuff and
he'd been like ya know you have to leave
and then they'd gotten into an argument
and maybe she had shot him hmm so that's
kind of another possibility however I do
think that there is another possibility
kind of related to this one that might
be a little bit more on the nose and
that would be Charlotte Shelby who was
Mary miles Minter's mother oh yeah now
according to everybody that knew this
woman she was like the textbook example
of like the horrible stage mother Brian
you know what I mean
she liked Mary miles Minter they had her
and her mother had like a complicated
relationship and she had another
daughter too named Margaret and both of
the girls were kind of messed up they
both had like a lot of mental issues and
had been on medication and spent time to
silence things like that now apparently
this mother was just adamant about
keeping Mary's reputation unsullied and
when she found out that Mary was in love
with Taylor apparently Charlotte made it
a point of like threatening him like all
this to stay away from my daughter or
I'll kill you she actually said that him
in public of several times she had
everybody knew that she had like a 38
that she would carry around several
other actors and directors at the time
said that she had come to the set and
like waved it around at the
you know like threatened to shoot them
if they look super like touching her
daughter wrong or like looking at her
daughter wrong or something like that so
she was kind of a crazy person so it
should be noted too that when they did
like you know when they looked at the
bullet wound on Taylor it did appear
that it come from a 38 and it was kind
of an unusual type of bullet and
apparently she had some of those bullets
in her house so a lot of people I think
sources differ on this one has ever had
like a bunch of different sources about
this particular case some people are
into like the drug dealer thing some
people are into like you know the valet
thing most people think that it was
either Mary Miles mentor the 19 year old
or it was her mother Charlotte Shelby
just because either because of
unrequited love or because of like
Charlotte she'll be wanting him because
she had threatened to kill him before if
she didn't stay away from her daughter
now for a while I was thinking that
probably it was Charlotte Shelby but
then I was watching another documentary
about this earlier that kind of made me
lean back toward Mary miles mentor again
because they said that the way that the
bullet hole had entered his body it
looked like the person that shot him had
been hugging him you know what I mean
like the way that his arm was like the
angle of it they said now this person
would have had to shot him from very
very very close range and his arm would
have had to been raised because it like
went like in twos backer like in here
and like came out or something like that
like there's like a little you know like
a look at chart that shows you they
didn't record they didn't recover the
gun no not the gun what about the bullet
I think they did it like I said they did
find like a bullet casing did they say
what caliber top 38 I said it was 38
I've said that several put in and it was
in it was ejected I don't know I'm just
saying they knew that it was a 38 so
well they found the case you found the
case of the bullet but if they found the
case I mean that that means that it was
an automatic and it injected the fdk
maybe it was the bullet then because
they did say they did have 38 automatics
they had 38 acp at that time and yet had
they had like 380 I'm just trying to
think of you know could have been could
have been a 38 ACP and early Colt but
that's not really something that a woman
would carry well that's the time I mean
maybe now that I'm thinking about it
maybe they found it the bullet if it was
still lodged in there because they did
say it was a like an unusual type of
bullet because they also found the same
bullets at Charlotte Shelby's home and
she was known to have a 38 that she
would wave around a lot about something
like 38 short Colt some [ __ ] like that
which is a small weak 38 revolver
cartridge yeah and no no recoil pop gun
really by today's standards and because
those revolvers were kind of small and
they were very tamed to shoot that would
be something that a woman might have
yeah she had it yeah so yeah yeah I mean
numerous witnesses did say that she had
it like she was quite well most about
having that in the 20s 38 ACP would have
been Adem basically a military cartridge
yeah that'd have been something that you
know I mean somebody with military
experience would own yeah
there's a full-power cartridge by those
standards at powerful cartridges yeah by
that day standards you know so the so
the only thing that's making me think
because at first I was thinking oh it's
Charlotte Shelby it's the mom because
she hated him she had like threatened to
kill him she had the gun everything like
that I read in several sources that
after that information about the bullets
went public she threw the gun into like
a bayou and Louisiana or some [ __ ]
allegedly so for a while I was thinking
it was her but then when they said well
it looked like the person that shot him
had been hugging him that made me lean a
little bit more toward Mary because one
Taylor and Charlotte Shelby the mom
hated each other so why would they be
hugging I mean I really doubt that she
you know Charlotte had spent so long
like threatening him I doubt that if she
showed up at his house and was like hey
let's let bygones be bygones
mere man let me give you a hug I don't
know if that would have gone down like
that hmm
however had Mary showed up his house
what she had done before um David Pookie
she's attacking a camera which she had
done before it's you know let's say she
had shown up that evening unexpected um
you know she'd been like I said she'd
been wearing her like sexy lingerie or
whatever like under a trenchcoat she
comes in there and she's just like hey
love me marry me or whatever and he's
just like you know no man I can't do
this right now or whatever and then she
gets upset you know or she's like trying
to hug on him and stuff like that and
she either on purpose or accidentally
like shoots him like under his arm like
in the back or something like that that
sounds fairly likely because I didn't
mention because I just remembered it
just now that earlier on uh Mary Minter
had apparently according to her family
had threatened to kill herself and then
run upstairs and like shot a gun off and
then when they went running up there she
was like laying on the ground like with
a gun in her hand and stuff and they
were all like oh my god she's dead and
then she got and then she woke up and
she was like aha just kidding so she
does that kind of [ __ ] so this is
clearly not a stable woman yeah that was
more common back then you think though
true there was a lot when women used to
attempt suicide all the time in the
early 1900s to uh to get their way and
you know they were doing it in Europe
too but that was pretty common a matter
of fact a bunch of women evidently
committed suicide or attempted or
pretended to commit suicide behind Adolf
Hitler during before he came to power
some of them were his cousins yeah
because Germans married cousins which
was you know kind of marry when you
think about it but I think he had two of
them or at least one of them one of them
that tried twice and it was that same
kind of theme that was in the [ __ ]
culture of the West at that time a woman
couldn't get the man she wanted she
thought it [ __ ] fit she'd pull a gun
and boom either shoot herself for real
or pretend yeah it became a it was
cultural [ __ ] phenomenon at the time
kind of weird whatever was drama queens
or drama queens guns were that's why I'm
kidding you know wouldn't surprise me if
the mom had done it because she had you
know means and motive um
however it also wouldn't surprise me if
Mary had done it and I'm not saying that
she did it on purpose I don't think if
she did do it I don't think she went
there intending to kill him I think she
went there I mean she could have taken
her mom's gun you know what I mean from
the house she knew where it was and um
you know she could have gone there with
the intention of like getting the D or
getting him to like ask her to marry him
or something like that and then he
didn't want to do it it wasn't going the
way she wanted and maybe she was kind of
trying to like rub up on him like hey
come on man or something like that and
maybe maybe or maybe she was drunk and
she [ __ ] up though I must say no my
experience with firearms shooting
somebody like that up close is just
never an accident yes it's an
assassination you have to want to shoot
somebody's give her the benefit of the
doubt and what it was if that's the
scenario and I'm skeptical of that but
if that was a scenario somebody grabbed
him in a ploy you don't I mean to get to
like they ever hug at him and then put a
pistol up to him pull the trigger yeah I
mean somebody did kill him so somebody
had always might have been some jealousy
[ __ ] I can't Harry I can't have you so
no one's gonna have you that's like yeah
that's probably what it was but I'm real
skeptical about all this angular [ __ ]
because a lot of times that involves
lawyers in court in courts and they're
trying to come up with some kind of an
explanation to find somebody innocent or
guilty so they say well this person must
have been doing this and this meant a
lot of [ __ ] can be interpreted four or
five different ways yeah that's maybe
the angle was funny because he was
leaping to his own defense and trying to
get away from somebody would get fired
on him yeah some people said maybe his
arms were right like maybe they were up
like hey don't shoot me or something
yeah there's a bunch of different ways
you can interpret bullet angles in a lot
of different ways depending on who's
telling you to damn story yeah but I
think
probably like like you said I think it
was unrequited love some some [ __ ]
like that's it I'm I can't have you no
one's gonna have you that type of deal
you're humiliating me why not you know
sealing the deal here and you know maybe
he tagged it yeah yeah I mean so he had
it broken a promise to get with her
something like that yeah it could be
it's it's and the mom made him may have
known yeah and then he's backing out on
the deal you know I mean yeah after he
tagged it yeah so they go down any mama
goes down there and [ __ ] puts a
bullet in him forgot a [ __ ] CAD what
they called it back then yeah and those
days a CAD should be noted that um
Charlotte Shelby's other daughter
Margaret Shelby who is also an actress
um even though she had her own mental
health issues and stuff like that she
was convinced that the mom had done it
probably it sounds like it to me she
thought the market that's kind of said
well like I said the mom is the one that
was going around saying I'm gonna kill
you you [ __ ] yeah well she
sounds to be kind of like you know the
moms are those little childhood beauty
queens that's exactly what this is where
they raise up and she's got an army of
[ __ ] beauty queens out there to make
money and fame yeah and then they're
trying to marry her off to this dude you
know she puts out they think the [ __ ]
paydays coming the marriage is coming
and then all of a sudden he kicks her to
the curb and she's like you need that
[ __ ] I'm gonna kill him yeah it's gonna
be something like that and like I said
she had threatened him like said yeah
that's probably was now another weird
wrinkle in this case though and this
happened later on now there was this
other woman who was she was another
silent era actress named Margaret Gibson
now she had actually worked with Taylor
when she when he first came to Hollywood
like back in the there in the late 1910s
now she had a little bit of a criminal
record I think she had convictions for
like opium dealing prostitution stuff
like that so she got in kind of a little
bit of trouble with the law
and it was affecting her career so she
changed her name to something else and
like started acting under another name
for Trisha Palmer I think she did
extortion and [ __ ] as well now she
seemed to have gotten work as an actress
prior to that however on her deathbed
in 1964 she gathered like all her family
around said hey I got to tell you guys
something
I killed William Dean Taylor who sounds
good so I don't know why she that might
have been if she did it I don't know why
she would have confessed on her deathbed
yeah but you know and this was many
years later this was in the sixty might
be true she did know him she had worked
with him early on what'd she say I
that's all she said she said he killed
him she didn't say the reason or
anything huh I don't like so there's no
crazy that crazy so yeah that she
confessed that in 1963 before she died
yeah I shot it but she didn't say why
are you thanking like I said I would
assume that it was unrequited love
probably yeah he [ __ ] her over because
she knew him they had worked together
although it's weird because I don't
think she was on the police's radar
initial I maybe that's why the case was
never solved maybe that's why cuz she
was the one that didn't nobody thought
nobody suspected her yeah maybe not yeah
so I definitely do think she went down
even though there were like some other
yes he had a couple of valets that could
have done it you know he had that one
valet that is like [ __ ] him over in
the past
Edwards hands I think his name was and
he had done [ __ ] before so it's possible
that guy could have done it yes it could
have been drug dealers and stuff like
that to me this seems more like one of
the ladies I think one of the ladies did
this one sounds like it I mean it
definitely does seem like a lot of the
[ __ ] breaks hearts and [ __ ] you
know yeah he was a good-looking fella
you know and he probably had that like
you know that he had that British accent
and everything now as I forgot what
country he was in I guess yeah he's
women a [ __ ] take care yeah
especially old Hollywood back there
like I said they didn't have the
forensic technology if he were slick and
you could get away with it which whoever
did it got away and then you know these
actresses had what it took to charm
their way through a police interrogation
like I would never do ever do you know
how they are just like that [ __ ]
musical Chicago yeah
[Laughter]
you forgot where yeah like I said so uh
this murder like I said it's still
unsolved known has any idea like who
killed him and it was definitely one of
the scandals I mean there was a bunch of
other ones including Fatty Arbuckle and
a couple other like drug overdoses and
things like that that happened around
the same time that contributed to the
bringing in of the Hays Code and the
moral turpitude clauses that actors had
to sign and everything like that it's
funny like the Hays Code the [ __ ] they
brought in up so you couldn't do like
any kind of sexual anything anymore it's
like you had to you know it's new sex
perversion know this that the other that
was all in the Hays Code it's just like
[ __ ] hilarious
and little black things in there I don't
know I don't think it's a bug it was
flat kind of like a I don't know I think
it was a drinking led page right here
little Japanese bamboo yeah I think
that's where camera yeah all right okay
we're back and we're back and I found a
name of that girl that I was thinking of
her name was Louise Lee go ahead and
google up Louise Brooks maybe Jenny will
show some pictures of her but that woman
was that was a hundred years ago and
look how mommies he like thinking about
and look how modern now that we've
licked her she always seemed like a she
always seemed yeah I'll check and she
had she was super cool she had a lot of
really cool photo photo shoots art deco
a lot of it was kind of semi nude some
of it really cool [ __ ] hair I mean
you could make movies with her now
that's how cool no one would bat an eye
no she was a little skinny for my taste
but that's just the way the old that's
just the way you know all that could
flapper look was back well yeah they
were all very small but yeah Louise
Brooks [ __ ] stylish yeah like I said I
was dug her like I like a lot of that
silent era that look you know what I
mean and she was up to some [ __ ] - she
was talks about it me you can find it
find out you know go to Germany and
hanging out in the damn lesbian clubs
and stuff and just
this is a trip like I said she seemed
like a cool chick yeah but yeah I also
wanted to say too I think it just
occurred to me that I think when we were
talking about the last case I kept
saying William Dean Taylor weren't
sexually William Desmond Taylor I don't
know why I was doing that yeah I guess
because our Dean Taylor was the guy that
did ghosts in my house that's never
maybe that's why I was thinking of Dean
but yeah it's Desmond actually this next
stunt this next one's a good one to
Fatty Arbuckle yeah this happened right
around the same time and again this was
another case like another scandal
yeah contributed to the Hays Code coming
in and like you know yeah I'm gonna be
into this story because I don't really
know it's true I've heard a lot of
different [ __ ] stories about him when
[ __ ] putting bottles up in wait a
minute that is that is not it's not
happen okay that was that was something
that was added much later on he was a
comedian big fat guy who he had a real
[ __ ] positive like persona his his
public image was that he was just a real
fun guy and then he turns up dead as I'm
chick no he wasn't he didn't it wasn't
that one no no no it doesn't some didn't
some chick die yeah but I'm a yeah yeah
he turns up with some dead chick is what
I meant so I that's not really kinda
that's the story that they wanted to
tell you yeah well I feel like even at
the time I mean there was a lot of [ __ ]
made up at the time because like I said
you know people talk about [ __ ] nowadays
but it's like back then they just had
they had no like scruples at all about
just like making [ __ ] up and famous
paper they would just put whatever they
didn't care yeah and it's like well no
it's not as bad as it used to be it's
not seriously it's not they called it
whether they call it yellow journalism
yeah it's it's really not I've read
several books about that era and it's
like it's much better now than I used to
be trust me but yes so Fatty Arbuckle
fatty was obviously not his name and he
hated that nickname that was something
that the studios gave him his actual
name was Roscoe Arbuckle he actually got
started I didn't know this but he got
started in the Keystone Cops silence and
he was actually spotted by a producer he
was like the only fat Keystone cop but
he was a really good physical comedian
they said even though he was you know
quite large
I believe he was 266 pounds yeah which
well it's not that fat by today's
standards I guess but back then it was
actually pretty long wait but you know
and he cared the way he carried it he
looked like you know a fat person it's
like cuz some people I've seen some
people that weighed 266 he wouldn't they
wouldn't know just depends where you
carry but they said that even though he
was 266 pounds he was very like graceful
and very acrobatic like I said he was a
very good physical comedian so he kind
of stood out like in the Keystone Cops
and he eventually ended up getting a
contract with Paramount Pictures now
after this he'll like he made a [ __ ] ton
of movies and at one point he was the
highest-paid actor in the world I don't
even think it was like comedic actor I
think it was just actor actor like he
got a million dollar contract in like
1921 [ __ ] that's when nobody had that
that's like a hundred million dollar you
know any more than 100 million I don't
think it's that much but it's like it
was a lot like nobody nobody had that at
least fifty million dollars so it was a
lot of money but there's a and he was um
and he was uh I believe he mentored
Charlie Chaplin he was also really good
friends with Buster Keaton like they
worked together a lot and he worked with
like a lot of the leading starlets of
the time including Mabel Normand who we
talked about last time so he was kind of
on top of the world they had a giant
house giant car it was just like really
really successful everybody knew who he
was around the world
he was just in all these silent films
really funny everybody loved the guy and
then came Labor Day weekend
1921 now accounts differ about what
happened I have my own opinions about
what happened I wasn't there obviously
but yeah I do think that a lot of the
[ __ ] it's it kind of sucks that that's
the only thing people remember him for
nowadays yeah because I'm pretty sure it
didn't go down the way people think that
it went down you know I'm saying so
Labor Day weekend he's decided like he's
been working a lot so he decides to take
a couple of his friends and they're
gonna go you know kind of have a big
party at one of his favorite hotels the
st. Francis hotel in San Francisco now
they rented three rooms
one of the rooms was for him and like a
friend of his and then there was another
room for one of the other guys and then
the other room was like the party room
so they had set up this room with just
like food everywhere they had illegal
booze like I said prohibition so they
still had all the booze in their drugs
presumably I would think - so they have
like a room so people were like in and
out like all weekend do you know what I
mean like it was a three-day type of
thing now one of the women that turned
up at the party was a 26 year old
actress named Virginia Rappe a now she
was kind of known as a lot of people
were at the time like especially
actresses like I said you know it was a
very party centric era so she was kind
of known as a party girl so she turns up
at the party um like early afternoon or
something like that and somehow by the
end of the day she didn't die that day
she was actually what ended up happening
was that she they thought something was
the matter with her they initially they
thought she was just really really drunk
um because she was acting very strangely
said she couldn't breathe she started
like tearing at her clothes and things
like that so they thought something was
the matter with her
the weird thing was that they didn't
take her to a hospital right away they
took her to like a sanitarium or some
[ __ ] like that and then she kind of was
ah yeah and then she ended up dying two
days later now huh must have been some
kind of mixture of it was she was on
drugs and she wants been sick well I'll
get into that you know what I mean I'm
gonna get into them now because I don't
think I can't really think of any drug
offhand that they had access to
recreationally that would make you not
be able to breathe well okay so so
here's what happened now the only reason
that Fatty Arbuckle got into trouble for
this I think so Virginia Rappe a had
come to the party with a couple of her
friends and one of her friends was named
Maude Delmont now she reported to police
that
Arbuckle was drunk and Virginia was also
kind of drunk and that she mod said that
she saw Fatty Arbuckle like essentially
strong-arming Virginia into a room
saying something like I've waited for
you for five years and now I've got you
then she said that she heard screaming
coming from the other side of the door
you know the locked door of Arbuckle's
room and then apparently you know this
friend like goes in the room finds
Virginia in there she's all like naked
she's moaning and pain or whatever she's
asked she says something it was like
thirty minutes or so go like that and
she says something like he did it or he
hurt me or something like that and then
they you know they go and they put her
in a tub or something like that and then
they were like calling the hotel doctors
now the hotel doctors that came to the
room they seem to think that she was
just intoxicated which is why they
initially just sent her to a sanitarium
they didn't send her to a hospital
because it didn't look like there's a
growing anything was wrong with her
other than her being super super drunk
they said she was acting like she was
super drunk but that was about it they
didn't see any bruises - been drinking
some damn bathroom well yeah that's well
like I said there was some bootleg hooch
going yeah
now if you guys don't know I'm talking
about booze this you know of course this
prohibition brew boost is illegal and
some you know you couldn't get [ __ ]
high quality shits back in the days and
kiss you too young I've explained that
dad come in and explain to you sometimes
you had to like cook up some hooch in a
damn bathtub they call it a bathtub gin
and if a guy didn't know what he was
doing is instead of instead of methyl
alcohol was ethyl alcohol and there's
all kinds of weird mistakes you could
make that's I mean you're making died
you were taking your life in your hands
because there's more than one kind of
alcohol and the distillation processes
can be finicky if you don't you don't
follow it perfectly or you use the wrong
ingredients you can make gasoline if you
dream yeah
drink then you drink protein did you
drink that you go blind and you know
what that might suffocate you that you
might feel like you have this but like I
said that either that's not one but
usually what it is is you get blind
drunk and you can't it [ __ ] up your
vision it can kill you
yeah but we'll see let's see what happen
what what it is we'll see how the story
goes so yes so they take this poor woman
away mmm now even though this Maude
woman who came to the party with
Virginia I think fatty new Virginia
previously cuz she was kind of like
well-known like in Hollywood or whatever
um I don't know if he knew Maude as well
like or maybe he had just met her that
day or whatever so Maude essentially
says to the police well fati dragged her
into the hotel room and raped her and
then later on she turned up dead so
obviously he murdered her so fatty gets
arrested now according to his story he's
like here's what actually happened he's
like we're all at the party because it
was a [ __ ] ton of people there it was
three hotel rooms like I said there was
one party room and there was a couple
rooms like one was fatty and his friend
and then like the other was like some
other guy's room he's like here's what
happened he's like I had this other
friend that needed a ride into town or
needed a ride in Napa or something like
that he's like and I was in my pajamas
cuz it was party weekend you know so I
hadn't put any clothes on so um he's
like so I said okay well I'll take you
and he went to his room to put clothes
on and he said he found Virginia Rappe a
in his bathroom throwing up so he
thought as most people did apparently
that she was just had just had too much
to drink
so he was like hey you okay and kind of
like you know after she was done
throwing up like kind of put her out on
the bed
he also said later that he had kind of
got some ice and like tried to cool her
off and stuff because she seemed like
she was kind of you know upset and
everything and then he was just like
okay well and she went he went and told
like some of the other people at the
party hey you know she's kind of [ __ ]
up maybe we should do something about it
they called the hotel doctor's hotel
doctor said yeah she's probably had too
much to drink you know do you want us to
take her to the to the
the same salary whatever they said yeah
you know she should take care of her or
whatever and then Fatih said that he
left and drove his friend to wherever it
was that she was going and he said I
never you know I wouldn't rape a woman
he's like I've never done that in my
whole entire life I would never do such
a thing
that's the kind of fame and money that
he had that time I don't think he'd have
to
and yet and most of his friends said the
same thing they said he's seriously they
said he was the nicest dude ever they
said he was really shy around women
women actually and that he wasn't like
that at all so yeah he didn't Weinstein
there I don't think that yeah that's
what I'm saying so now it turned out
that Virginia Rappe a did die two or
three days later
now even though initially they thought
it was alcohol poisoning or something
like that when they did an autopsy they
discovered that she had died that she
actually had peritonitis and that she
had died of a ruptured bladder so they
thought perhaps because I've seen like
different sources say that she knew that
she had peritonitis like for a long time
like it's a cry it was a chronic
condition okay and that she was kind of
a drinker and alcohol drastically
exacerbates that [ __ ] that condition
okay so that she was kind of well known
for going to parties and drinking too
much right and then she would start like
writhing in pain she would start tearing
at her clothes all right make sense
and stuff like that so they said she was
kind of like so they did an autopsy they
found that now the fact that she had a
ruptured bladder though made some people
think oh well maybe Fatty Arbuckle was
trying to rape her
and he was so fat that it busted open
her bladder died we live in an age of
porn and we can see anything today and
have you ever seen a woman's bladder be
ruptured by screwing a fat dude I have
not I don't believe it's possible I'm
just saying that's why I don't worry as
possible.i I think it's all starting to
make sense to me now what it was is she
had peritonitis she admitted to it
that's a frequency and they found it in
the autopsy there's a pre-existing
condition she was known for drinking a
lot and [ __ ] trying to tear herself
up because because it was very painful
you know painful
probably what happened was is that she
got some common infection that's kind of
when she started drinking on top of it
and then it kicked in and somehow it ate
through that damn the infection that she
had prior he had to ate through her
bladder not I mean or compromised her
bladder in a certain area and her
bladder swelled up from all the drinking
and it ruptured that's what I suspecting
and then and then it went into her
abdominal cavity went into her body and
that'll [ __ ] you up quick yeah okay
because it should be noted I'm toxic
it's set well again sepsis yeah sepsis
cuz I mean we're talking about the 1920s
but even in the 1920s like the doctors
that came in examined her I mean they
didn't know about the peritonitis they
didn't know but anything that they just
thought she was like really really
intoxicated so that's kind of that what
they were operating on but they did note
that she did not look as though she had
been raped she was not bruised she did
not have any there were no like signs of
violence on her anything like that she's
probably just drunk and lashing out and
it took you know and like I said it did
take several days like she died like two
or three days later and really the only
I mean most of the other people at the
party
they either hadn't seen what happened
because they were all partying and they
weren't really paying attention or they
said yeah um fatty just went in there
and like found her in the bathroom
throwing up like she was sick and like
you know kind of rubs rice on her
something like that like trying to like
chill her out or like they put her in a
tub of cold water or something see how
this goes in this happens to him in the
age of yellow journalism and it's good
looking good it's gonna take a crazy ass
direction where he did this and it did
sell a lot of papers yeah and it does
seem that like you know one woman that
had been at the party that said that she
saw a fatty like drug and I think there
was one other person that maybe said
like something similar which is why they
have been perusing to say that it might
have been worse to say that for money
for the damn newspapers because you know
yeah
and we're like that was worth a lot of
and listen to this [ __ ] it's like even
nowadays like if they print like stupid
[ __ ] they at least like have the you
know decency to like not be so [ __ ]
blatant about it back in the old days
when like William Randolph Hearst owned
the [ __ ] they didn't [ __ ] means yeah
he basically said that when Fatty
Arbuckle got arrested and like was on
trial and stuff he's like we're selling
more papers than when the [ __ ]
Lusitania sank yeah like he said
something like that yeah like so you
didn't care if it was true or not he
just wanted to like sell newspapers does
this be a lesson to you people [ __ ]
lies salacious lies sell better than the
truth well always an awesome story so
awesome whether it's true or not it
doesn't really matter on history it's
been that way throughout history it's
been everybody wants salacious details
yeah so I'm just kind of saying it's
like I you know I wasn't there it's like
I don't I don't like to get into a thing
where it's like oh now we're not
believing like raping victims and stuff
because that's not my intention the
evidence were there in this situation I
definitely think that this was a case of
somebody at a party maybe they were
inebriated maybe something maybe they
saw something they didn't really see her
they misinterpreted something and maybe
they had good intentions maybe not I
don't know but the problem with this is
I really don't think Fatty Arbuckle had
anything to do with it now the poor guy
was put on trial three times wait a
minute for manslaughter three times for
rape and manslaughter yeah well what
ended up happening the first time he
went on trial he actually he testified
and the jury was 10 to 2 to acquit yeah
um there was one woman on the jury that
said I don't give a [ __ ] whatever I hear
and the thing I'm gonna do guilty or
whatever because she was like dead set
she thought he was a monster or whatever
she wrote he decided that all right um
so it was a hung jury so they had to
have a retrial so then they had a second
trial and Fatty Arbuckle thought that or
at least his defense attorney was like
well you know we've had like so much new
[ __ ] come out about people that were
like bribed to say this yeah some people
bribed to say that but he didn't think
that Fatih needed to
needed to testify which maybe it was
kind of a mistake because in that trial
I think it was opposite I think it was
ten to two to you know convict but it
was still a hung jury so then they had
to do a read another retrial a third one
now this retrial they acquitted him not
only did they acquit him but the judge I
believe came out and said acquittal
isn't good enough leave this poor
[ __ ] man alone he didn't do anything
like I said I'm paraphrasing
that's essentially what they said it's
like he really [ __ ] didn't do
anything there's no evidence that he did
anything to this girl was just a media
pileup it's like yeah it's like it
became a witch huh yeah it's like all
that happened was he found this girl who
he kind of knew in his bathroom he tried
to help her he was a bishop that guy and
then he was just like hey can you guys
look out for her I got some [ __ ] to do
and then he left right so it kind of
looked like that's what happened he was
the bad guy
and so they [ __ ] zoomed in on his ass
for a bunch of different reasons yeah
because rich fat guy was [ __ ] he must be
up to something
he must be abusing the women if he's
rich and fair [ __ ] soiling all these
[ __ ] skinny pretty girls that's one
angle another angle is is that if we can
get this story to fly we'll make all
kinds of money is [ __ ] well missus he
is yeah yeah it is and there was and
like I said it came out later the boat
was all kind of like blackmail and [ __ ]
like that like going out like people
paying people off to say this yeah and
people have to say that about it a lot
of the movie studios were telling their
actors because some actors that were
coming out like Charlie Chaplin and
stuff like that wanted to come out and
like support of him because they didn't
think he'd done anything and the studios
were saying don't you [ __ ] dare say
anything or there will be consequences
think about this this is a 1920s
underground [ __ ] party of [ __ ]
celebrities Hollywood celebrities you
know I mean they all got a shift out of
money they're drinking illegal booze
taking all kinds of drugs there's a lot
of them there isn't any even pride
there's not really any privacy to speak
of there's no rape gonna go down in
there yeah I mean I'm not saying that it
did happen cuz it did but I'm just
saying a good rapper in this case I
don't even think he didn't I think he
just found her in the bathroom he's like
hey you alright and put her in the bed
laughs yeah witnesses that said that
yeah I think that's all that happened
that he had anything to do with anything
I say he was on his way out the door he
said he just came in the room like to
change his clothes to take his friend
somewhere could to give her a ride
someplace no I think he just found her
and she said that he heard him but that
woman was out of her mind with [ __ ]
and this well and this woman too might
have had a beef against him because I
think that she had actually sent
telegrams to attorneys later on that
said stuff like we have fatty in a hole
here let's make some money off him [ __ ]
like that like she would say [ __ ] like
that so I think she kind of like
concocted the story for some reason of
her own because like I said most the
other people at the party either didn't
see anything or just said hey you know
that girl was just here and he was just
trying to help her out and then he left
like to give his friend a ride so I
don't know where that all came this
whole believe all women when it comes to
rape that doesn't fly there are women
that just proven have lied about it
there there was one case that I can
think of where guy walks in on his wife
she's in a damn car where the dude
having sex with this now this other dude
all right it's a white woman the dude is
black the husband finds her she tells
the husband that he raped her the black
dude the black dude was his was her
trainer in the gym big muscle guy he
actually went to prison later on she
divorced too that [ __ ] husband and
then came clean said nah I just said
that to protect my marriage sent that
dude to [ __ ] prison
see that's what I mean but for that but
the thing is about is I'm really
uncomfortable like yes I know [ __ ] like
that happens yes I know people are
terrible and stuff but I feel like
dwelling on the very few times that that
happens makes it so that people that
actually got raped which is far more
common yeah like don't want to come
forward right so it's like I'm really
really remind about that like I don't
want like I don't want innocent people
to get accused of anything not on it not
all women are honorable no they're not
but the thing about
is that you no false rape accusations is
maybe like one or two percent it does
happen though that has happened but it's
a very small percent yes so I think that
I mean in in pretty much 99.9 percent of
the cases or 98 percent of the cases you
should give the victim the benefit of
the doubt because very unlikely I mean
the the false as far as I know the false
you know the false accusations for rape
are the same as false accusations for
any other crime which is like I said
it's about two percent so it's not like
so it's not like there's this big wave
of like people like falsely accusing
people of that kind of [ __ ] so I think
that you should always err things most
women don't have the balls
well why it's it's a terrible thing to
do like if you do that you're a terrible
person I mean it's using somebody of
anything that they didn't do right rape
burglary whatever is that's a shitty
thing to do and just don't do that but
I'm just saying that and the fact and it
makes it worse because when you do that
all the people that did get raped now no
one will believe them because of your
stupid ass so it's like please please do
not do anything like that
but yeah so I feel like this wasn't even
the victim did that did that it was just
some other woman that got Fatty Arbuckle
arrested because she said hey I saw him
drag my friend or this girl that I knew
like into the room um as far as I know
Virginia Rappe a never said anything
about that because she was like really
sick and so I don't think all he all she
said reportedly was something like he
hurt me or something like that which a
lot of people have said well that could
be because of the other guy that like
put her in the bathtub full of cold
water you know what I mean like it could
have been lots of things um she wasn't
able to testify so you'll never know
yeah should have been that might have
been hearsay right it's like yeah you
don't know because like I said there was
so many people everybody been there like
drinking for like two or three days
straight so you're not really sure like
what entirely happened but in this case
I really really don't think that Fatty
Arbuckle did anything I just think that
he found the girl his bathroom was like
his life though yeah it pretty much did
because after that even though he got
acquitted and the judge even made a
point of saying you know
quibbles not good enough it's like leave
the man alone he didn't do anything he's
totally innocent um you know the stink
of the scandal still surrounded him
right couldn't get back in there and he
really couldn't get back in - I mean he
was in he um he did work with Buster
Keaton because Buster Keaton was kind of
like the only one that kind of had the
balls to like come out like against the
studio's and say hey shut the [ __ ] up or
whatever he actually got reprimanded for
that by the studio but he was like I
don't care he's my friend so he actually
did and he gave fatty artwork we'll work
later on and arbuckle did um direct a
few movies like under a pseudonym which
I think was William Goodrich or
something like that like he had a
pseudonym that he directed under but he
never obviously never regained his you
know the the fame that he had had before
even though some of his later movies
that Buster Keaton put him in were like
very successful because by that few
years had gone by and people have
forgotten about it yeah kind of pad that
out that was a [ __ ] terrible what
happens when you look at it that way but
this version the Hollywood wasn't wasn't
gonna last much longer anyway within a
few decades it had totally changed yeah
and he wouldn't have made the conversion
anyway I don't think but you know I mean
because modern problem or modern
Hollywood came and a lot of the silent
actors didn't make the transition they
basically rebooted Hollywood well yeah
because it's a totally different I mean
films with sound or a completely
different thing yeah than silent films
and a lot of actors did not make that
train engine success yeah and it
producers the producers and everything
in the heads of the heads of the studios
wanted a almost a clean reboot they
wanted all new stars and everything I
think they I think some of the directors
made it but most of the stars didn't
make the version well if you're behind
the camera that's different yeah the
crews and stuff if you're in front of
the camera though and even if you look
good and the silent films but that alone
when you talk you sound like yeah you
know I mean it's like no one's gonna
hire you sound like that yeah they just
wanted to they they wanted a fresh start
the silent film
I like side I like silent film
thought it was kind of visual I like
salad films actually yeah it was they're
very the the late silent films were very
glamorous yeah
that you know but yeah so poor Fatty
Arbuckle um it it's sad because it
appeared that his career might have been
at the beginning of like kind of turning
around because like at one point in 1933
he had just had like a big meeting with
like some people they're like yeah we're
gonna do this that and the other thing
and um you know and I think he had
remarried and that that was like going
really well and stuff and I think he
said something like oh this has been
like the best day of my life or whatever
and then he went home and he died in his
sleep
he had a heart attack he was only 46
years old all that weight yeah yeah it's
not good but yeah you know maybe he
would have made it who knows yeah it's a
you know there's no way of knowing you
probably Maggie behind the camera yeah I
was and like I said he was able to
direct a few features like under a
pseudonym so like people didn't know and
Buster Keaton did like kind of stable
stand by him and he probably had enough
had he lived he probably had enough
money to stay to become a producer and
like be you know I mean stay in the game
behind the scenes
yeah paying for movies to be made yeah
that kind of but it's just kind of sad
how it just seemed like in this case
that there was just one person who
either had it out for him or saw
something that she misinterpreted right
and his whole entire career was ruined
and like I said it not only like ruined
his career but you know that along with
you know four or five other you know
scandals that were going on at the same
time that kind of changed Hollywood for
a long time like Hayes code like ever
suddenly everything because before and
the movies kind of anything went they
did it was a fairly new medium so you
could kind of get away with anything but
after the Hays Code came in that was the
whole you know married people can't
sleep in the same bed yeah you can't
have any kind of like you can't show
anybody's ankles or [ __ ] I don't even
know what it was but it was just like
this really really draconian like you
can't even show like the flag in a
certain way and it's like they had all
these like really weird like [ __ ] there
were some good horror movies pre Hayes
could go check out Boris Karloff and
Bela Lugosi's the black cat
there's also [ __ ] satanic and [ __ ]
[ __ ] going on about [ __ ] stealing
people's underage children and but can
you turn the women in like I say yeah
with a lot of sacrifice in [ __ ] whole
armies on the damn battlefield so you
could build your satanic castle and [ __ ]
but you got the black cat you could
probably see it for free on YouTube
I would imagine I've seen a lot was a
girly talkie
yeah the early talkie and it was pre
Hays Code and it was that was I think
that might have been one of the movies
why they decided that hey maybe we
should maybe like I said I think it was
mostly yeah cuz I think there was a lot
of like decadent [ __ ] going on in movies
too but I think it was mostly like
decadent chicken dude actors and stuff
dude collecting beautiful dead women and
putting them in damn [ __ ] clear
caskets and hanging them up for display
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] all of now she
she's so beautiful I never change now
age cannot touch her oh that's a good
that's a weird [ __ ] yeah that was like
you know oh I can't let this stand you
know I mean I gotta [ __ ] stop this
all those [ __ ] movies are great I
love Karloff didn't have anything to do
a growl and pose nothing to do with it
well I kind of feel like a lot of Edgar
Allan Poe adaptations don't have much of
anything to do with Edgar Allan Poe
although I must say I really I've always
really liked Roger Corman's Edgar Allan
Poe adaptation it's especially mask of
the Red Death with Vincent Price which i
think is wonderful
um but well his stories were so short
that if you're gonna make a movie out of
it you really kind of have to fill out
the backstory instead because I mean his
stories are essentially like just in
like a short episode yeah you know what
I mean
well black cat with Bela Lugosi and
Boris Karloff really did having it was
just an excuse to damn tell a damn Art
Deco satanic movie I mean that's what it
was and let's don't worry the black cat
was just about like a black cat who a
guy perceived it was tormenting him and
yet Walden yeah that's not really in the
movie right that's not in the mood a
black cat does jump out for a second
that's it that's it that's the rest of
it is that World War one a post-world
War one tail god damn it uh you know
what maybe I should talk about that on
some
on the on the Sunday sidetrack show
what's it is Edgar Poe adaptations okay
okay I want to talk about that because I
I don't think I've ever seen one that
adhered to the story all that closely
I mean pitting the pendulum like Roger
Corman's ones at least you could tell
that's what story it was adapted from
but some of the other ones just had the
toes Edgar Allen Poe's this and that and
then you'd watch it and be like that's
not what happened that's right they had
name recognition and you can make a
movie and yeah when you read the story
you like man we can't make a movie out
of that it's kind it's kind of like
kinda like Lovecraft some of the love
yeah stuff is so atmospheric there's not
enough there to dance today I make a
movie Poe is the same it's a yeah it
they're very different writers but
they're ones that they they conjure a
picture in your mind but it's really
hard to because so much of it is like
imagination and like world building and
stuff it's kind of hard to light and
it's kind of aerated it to the screen
it's the move the stories are narrated
so you know it's not quite the same
where we saw that one I think it's on I
don't remember if it's on Netflix or
shudder or whatever remember we saw it
once called I think it's called
extraordinary tales and it was like five
animated it was like five different
animators that had done this there and
they were different like adaptations of
post stories and they were actually
pretty faithful adaptations like they
did Kate facts in the case of M Valdemar
they did tell-tale heart which I think
was my favorite one and they did it like
three other ones but I remember liking
that quite a bit it could have been
better but I I remember the most
moveable of all the Lovecraft books
would have been in the mountain of
madness and they still haven't done that
one that's that one could be that one is
that yeah that way he's been saying that
[ __ ] for [ __ ] how long 15 years well
development hell is a thing it's a thing
you need quit doing that I know I mean
in mountains of madness would be on par
they never surpass [ __ ] like the
thing in scope it's just because you
know that would be a route
good good movie there are like more it
seems like there are more Lovecraftian
movies than there are movies actually
based on love graph stories yeah I'm
just saying yeah right it's kind of like
a hard thing to adapt same with cow like
I said that's it that's a topic I'm
gonna have to write that down I'm going
to talk about Poe adaptations cuz that's
something I was kind of cuz I was
working on a like a Poe trivia game not
too long ago so I was thinking about
movies that were based on both stories
so we don't fatty yeah we're doing with
fatty or Oh Fatty Arbuckle alright you
want to take a commercial break down
there and then we'll come back and we'll
talk about three more cases we'll talk
about George Reeves Natalie Wood and Bob
Crane when we come back on the second
it's probably gonna be like a really
long show yeah it's like no one's got
any place to go so might as well make it
as long as possible cuz we're not going
anywhere either weird you had us sitting
around here on Saturday night recording
a show for you guys so we'll be back in
just a few minutes
so what's llamas poopy up to today just
hanging out
oh my goodness she's like I don't want
to be in this old stop scratching yeah
where are we going where are we going
oh so you're rubbing against my back hey
don't you know when you're looking at
your wool rug
yeah it's not burrito time yet
that's an evening activity that she
loves beep yes oh my goodness oh my
goodness yeah what was that that's just
a video game it's okay
you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
baby's case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
okay we have returned
yes crimes of old Hollywood show yet we
are here to entertain you during the
apocalypse and approaches this like a
lot more boring than I thought the above
nothing like I imagined at all it's kind
of expecting I don't know an asteroid
strikes alright I was kind of seeing it
like in the way of kind of like
something out of Steely Dan or Donald
Fagen song you know me yeah that's all
right like your dad listened to Steely
Dan he did yeah yeah [ __ ] that's some
gangster music that's like a parallel
universe gang I like Steely Dan yeah I
like a lot of music might have liked
yeah I'm not one of those people it's
like shuttle I showed the submitted [ __ ]
to Sophie she's like this is like
something my Davin doesn't do well it is
yeah yeah well I mean she's a lot
younger than I said I might have says
probably her grandad yes my dad it's the
lyrics it's the lyrics and the lyrical
content
yes gangsta yeah but the thing about it
is that sometimes if music is like
really old it goes all the way back
around it because yeah right I mean cuz
I still listen to like [ __ ] from like I
like old blues music I like [ __ ]
rockabilly like really I like all that
stuff yeah all right so we're talking
about some more crimes talked about
fatty are welcome before talked about
William desmond taylor not Dane teller
as I kept saying for some reason now
let's talk about George
Superman Reeves yeah I kind of feel bad
for old George Reeves because he's
forever remembered as the guy who played
Superman even though he really did not
enjoy playing Superman yeah he was a
little out of shape actually by today's
standards well not by the standards of
the day not by the stands to those days
but by today's standards good because
you held member that at the time even
though he was wildly successful and
everybody knew who he was everybody
watched Superman and stuff like that but
back in those days like being on TV that
was like a step down like because he had
been a movie he was in Gone with the
Wind for chrissake yeah he was like one
of what's her face is like suitors or
retro TV was the YouTube of the day yeah
that was kind of like
where you went when you couldn't find
like real acting like if you were in
movies and stuff and that's how he felt
about it
little little did they know that [ __ ]
movies and TV are being destroyed by you
to think about you is that I mean now TV
and movies I think are almost almost on
an equal footing it's like nobody has
that stigma about oh I'm just doing like
a TV series anymore because look at all
the TV series that have like done really
well like critically and with audiences
and stuff like that so I don't think
there's like a step down in quality
anymore I think they're both on their
way outs can be put back in the old days
you know every like all if you were an
actor you wanted to be in movies that
was how you were like a real actor
that's where the money was if you were
just on TV that was kind of considered
like second-tier which you know you can
see how that was at the time and it was
even like that really up until the 70s
or 80s I think cuz I remember still like
having some actors that had that same
mentality like once they were kind of
like has bends you'd see them on TV you
know what I mean so I do see like where
that's coming from so I know where he's
coming from but that's the role that
he's most remember fortunately but you
know that's what are you gonna do so the
thing about okay so this happened in
1959 June 16th a phone call comes in to
the home of Phyllis Coates who played
Lois Lane on the old Superman show this
phone call came in about 4:30 in the
morning now the woman on the end of the
phone was a woman that she recognized
this was a woman named Toni Mannix now
Toni Mannix was married but she had been
carrying on an affair with George Reeves
for about ten years her husband knew and
apparently wasn't all that concerned
about it he must have had his own thing
god I think he had his own thing going
they were a very like high up Hollywood
couple so I think he was he was kind of
like okay fair enough um now I don't
think Tony Maddox was in a relationship
with him anymore because he was engaged
to another woman at this point but they
had been like a thing for like 10 years
and they were still friends or whatever
so Tony Maddox calls Phyllis Coates Lois
Lane and says
the boy is dead he's been murdered now
the boy was what she called George
Reeves and Phyllis Coates knew this so
you know freak outs ensued now like I
said George Reeves was very famous for
playing Superman he very famously also
did not like playing Superman although
once he figured out that like a lot of
kids were super into the show he was
very good about like going to like
children's hospitals in the outfit he
had a thing where at the end of each
season like when they've changed out the
costumes like they were gonna get rid of
the costumes he would cut the s off the
costume and he would like send it to a
kid like for their birthday or if they
were dying or something like that so he
was like really good about doing [ __ ]
like that even though I think that he
resented playing that character because
it was TV and he thought it was a step
down and also he just thought it was a
kids show paying the bills though I
think it largely was yeah but that's sad
that's what he's remembered for nowadays
that and you know the way that he died
oh well yeah that's the thing it was a
spoiled aren't they well boy it is [ __ ]
I it's weird because like as a creative
person like I can understand it but then
in another way I'm like quit bitching
because you're making like more money
than I'll ever see in my lifetime and
people remember you and people [ __ ]
like so in some ways you really kind of
have to look it because some people you
know like me like toil away in obscurity
and just like busy would I yeah bye and
it's like it's like quit your [ __ ]
whinging see what it is is that they
didn't care about what the fans thought
they just cared about what their peers
thought and they'd go to these reckon
parties and [ __ ] Hollywood people
looking down their noses at even oh my
god you play super and you know I mean
[ __ ] you I'm a paying the bills I got
fans yeah and I see that I can see that
yeah yeah but then I get it thus YouTube
was born we got our fans and that's it
our fans yeah that's what I mean that
for me like I said it as long as I met
an ad to be able to rent and buy food
good we don't even deal with any other
channels I don't you know I mean they
got some big-ass channels but we don't
deal with them they're not looking down
their noses at us we don't care no we
just got our own segment I watch other
people's channels like and if I like a
mall from a couple bucks every now and
then it is just that's just what you do
man they don't throw us any money though
you know not the other channels maybe no
no the super big now we're talking it
was super big channels yeah well I
wouldn't expect them to once you
well once you get to a certain level
there's so it's hard to keep track of
yeah you know actually nothing I got
people [ __ ] constantly [ __ ] talk
trying to talk to me on [ __ ] Facebook
I can't hold conversations with people
there's there's too many people you know
what I mean so if I'm just like giving
you a thumbs up going yeah yeah okay I
gotta go don't don't be offended well
yeah that's what I mean and like I
really draw people talk I really try to
at least like like everyone's comments I
try to comment too but it's like I don't
have time to do that - everybody's even
though I would like to but um it's like
I don't want anybody get offended about
it because I do yeah okay we're not even
a huge show we only have like 8,500 like
subscribers and it's still you guys
don't understand it would be a full-time
job just responding it to [ __ ]
replies I just just respond but yeah I
mean across all the platforms because I
get stuff in my email I can start a blog
I get stuff on you know what I mean so I
get stuff like in on all the stuff on
Instagram or whatever so it's like I try
to keep track of everything but it's
hard I'll get them on top shitty movies
I'll get about messenger I get them on
Facebook you know I mean it and it's
just I can't I can't talk to everybody
yeah don't be a thing we only have so
many hours and and like I said it's you
know I I'm editing the show I'm writing
books I'm doing graphic design work
although I haven't had much graphic
designer in the last few weeks cuz
everybody's on lockdown and no one's no
one's doing any shows and that's usually
what I did graphic design for was like
concerts and [ __ ] nobody's doing any of
YouTube's awesome because there's
interactive YouTube is awesome because
there's an interaction in it but they're
from our point of view there can't be
unlimited interaction it'll just what's
a full-time jobs the same thing it's
like you only have so much time in
you know what I mean it's like and I'm
not I mean I work a lot but we got to
produce stuff well and plus I still have
other [ __ ] to do it's like sometimes I
just want to relax and I sometimes I
gotta do laundry so there's a book you
know and sometimes I have to do other
things just like around the house I
gotta clean and show ya so it's like we
have other [ __ ] we gonna do - right so
you know I I do try to like keep up with
everybody because I know how it feels to
like be a big fan of a show and then
like they just like act like [ __ ] at
you or like ignore you or something so I
know how that feels and that sucks so I
do like try to at least yeah give you a
thumbs up or something like that like
just like hey I saw the [ __ ] it's like
maybe I'll go back and like answer it
later on but it's like a long time right
now and for all the stuff you see there
on the damn YouTube comments there's ten
times that [ __ ] personal going on
behind the foot seeds yeah that's a lot
well some of our like big fans that have
been with the show are on our personal
face right so we're talking to them so
we'll talk to them like I'll be [ __ ]
with Rob sometimes for hours on end he
does yeah Rob cuz he sends us a bunch of
movie yeah he's a filmmaker yes you guys
didn't know he and Mehmood yeah outlaw
which is awesome and I got a bus Rob's
balls cuz yeah he's up in New York our
buses [ __ ] balls I have fun with Rob
I love you [ __ ] all right but you know
I gotta [ __ ] with you that's what I do
all right
and then you know we talk Sophie
Sophie's personal friends then we got
personal just a two-hour house one time
for several days
she'll be back up that was a lot of fun
she's yeah she's [ __ ] awesome she's
welcome to come back yeah she can't stay
here any time and then you know it's
just other in that I got talked I got a
[ __ ] I gotta talk to GI year yeah dad in
Tijuana I talked to some people up and
[ __ ] Czech Republic sometimes you
know I mean so you know there's no
talent we're trying to keep track of
everybody we try to keep track of every
but it's are normally like I'm only one
person my memories good but not that
good
I know and I got my I got my feelers out
there on damn global level Trevor you go
with the [ __ ] going on with [ __ ]
corona on all kind of stuff because I
also got friends on there who are you
a muscle seen and also in the [ __ ]
military scene which I don't even talk
about that too much in the in during the
show but lots of vets a lot of veterans
and then a lot of people in the medical
like a lot of nurses because the nurses
are keeping me abreast of how shits
going with the corona corona my corona
yeah do you know what's up I kind of
love that song
for a while I had it on my phone and
like every now and then it would come on
while I was out of my power walking I'd
be like yeah it's about tearing up
underage girls it is yeah yeah it's
funny because you don't really think
about it like at the time that it came
out but now that I'm like walking I'm
listening to lyrics I like this kind of
messed up yeah when the sentence is
alright to tear up underage girls yeah
they weren't about it and I'm even
better not we're suing out she's like 16
yeah whatever it's not like she's a
little kid
ya know what I used to think back then
yeah that's hey man you were fair game
mm-hmm yes sir on the menu yeah so yeah
so what were we talking about George
Reeves yeah so the night that he died so
George Reeves is at home with who the
woman who was his fiancee at the time
whose name was Lenore lemon who had kind
of a reputation of being I'm not sure
what her reputation was like a lot of
people thought that she was kind of I
don't know if a ballbuster is the white
bright word but she seemed like kind of
me and abrasive something like that so
but he was completely smitten with her
so she was there there was also a writer
there named Robert Condon who was like
their larger he was like staying with
them or whatever
um they were kind of having a little bit
of party like a couple of their
neighbors came over on this particular
night you know I think George Reeves had
gone to bed early or he'd been drinking
really early Iran in the evening and was
kind of messed up because later on about
1:00 a.m. like when all when his you
know fiance and his houseguests and
stuff like that we're all kind of down
there I guess they were like making a
lot of noise so apparently he stops
downstairs
and is like hey can you guys like
[ __ ] keep it down because people are
trying to sleep in here or whatever and
apparently according to the other
witnesses and this is pretty weird so
according to the other witnesses George
Reeves comes down and yells at them for
presumably making too much noise and he
goes back up to his room and then his
fiancee Lenore starts telling the other
people in the house like some weird [ __ ]
like he's going upstairs to shoot
himself
that's what apparently she said
according to them and she said that they
said that she provided like running
commentary like the like they could hear
noise I'm serious it's like oh he's
opening the drawer he's getting the gun
out and then there was a gunshot and
then she's like look he did it
damn I don't know like I'm presuming
they were all drinking so maybe it was
kind of going in that direction you know
whatever so they go upstairs and it
appears that he has shot himself for
that's how the story goes anyway look
for you people who think that that [ __ ]
doesn't happen it does have him a friend
of mine did that yeah and rich Campbell
friend of mine dumped up in Boston got
into a fight with his girlfriend over
the goddamn volume of the [ __ ]
television during the Excalibur [ __ ]
movie Excalibur remember Excalibur we
said yeah we did a review and he goes
and he even mentioned me because that's
how I heard the story he's like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you don't know any honour and he
goes [ __ ] you know you could never
compare what he put on his [ __ ] army
[ __ ] jacket and [ __ ] and everything
and put a 38 pistol to his [ __ ] head
[ __ ] pull the trigger right in front
of his girlfriend that's the thing it's
like I I don't know like I know there's
a lot of controversy about George Reeves
and whether he killed himself or whether
somebody else killed him I don't know I
wasn't there but I will say that
depending on what your state of mind is
I can see a person getting so drunk that
they're just like man [ __ ] this and
they're not even really thinking it was
real all the way yeah rich didn't mean
it not only was he drunk at the time he
was junkie yes so he was a cool junkie
though I didn't even know he is [ __ ]
junkie yeah okay he kept the [ __ ] below
and he was a lot older than me 15 years
older than me you know I was talking
about Eric the guy from the you know I
had you guys seen a few little regular
listeners new Eric is he lived with me
down in Boston and that haunted house me
and Eric knew him he was cool dude
he was a fashion model and [ __ ] [ __ ]
we got some pictures of him [ __ ] when
he was back in the early 80s in the punk
rock scene modelling clothes and [ __ ]
but yeah he didn't mean it he was just
[ __ ] inebriated at the time his life
didn't go the way it was supposed to go
and she [ __ ] God she kept [ __ ]
with the damn volume of the television
and she was [ __ ] 20 years younger
than him she was cute you know but she's
another junkie you know and it's just I
know that luck with that heroin no
matter happen to like I said if you were
drunk enough and if you got in a fight
about it and if something kissed you off
enough yeah I could see how you would
just go just [ __ ] it without really
thinking about what you were doing there
was that's the thing about being super
drunk is you're kind of like not what
happened to rich is probably what
happened to him there's a bigger
overarching issue your life didn't go
the way you wanted it to yeah you were
already thinking about [ __ ] in it you
know I mean yeah but I can tell you one
thing in Rich's case [ __ ] he
overreacted yeah I mean [ __ ] and it
was a thing in the heat of the moment
yeah but like I said I can I can totally
see how that went right then I mean he
was at that time late 40s
he didn't look it yeah all his
girlfriends were in their [ __ ] 20s
and they were all like [ __ ] hotties
from the scene what is this [ __ ]
have to complain about
yeah yeah I mean but they know it's like
you can't really it's hard to look at
someone from the outside and it seems
like they have everything yeah what the
hell of you got to complain about but
you don't know what the [ __ ] issues are
going on behind the scenes or like
inside their heads or anything like that
it just like you never know life didn't
turn out the way he thought
what's going to it yes and that you know
they might have other problems that you
don't know about jail because you never
really know what's going on in someone
else's and his day after he died I
helped his brother [ __ ] clean that
place out we found a damn cat frozen in
the dam and in the freezer and I was
like what the hell man the cat was for
his cat what was he gonna bury it later
yeah what the deal was we finally
tracked down the X of an aster why was
the [ __ ] cat in the freezer and she
said oh the cat died and he wanted to
bury the cat but the ground was from the
ground was frozen
I've heard of that yeah the ground was
frozen so he wrapped it up in a garbage
bag
yeah and sealed everything I think I get
that and he was going what the hell is
this man opened up his damn frozen cat
well it was it was in a clear bag and I
was like okay that's a damn that's that
cat he had a new cat
that took its place yeah it wasn't that
bad what's as bad as that girl's head
well yeah yeah yeah you found all those
like kind of people on the bus so well
sooner if they through be the head in
the bag you know that thing that's not
as theory have you told that story in
the show I don't think I've ever told
this I remember you telling it a few
times at yeah horror convention when I
was is that like that stopped everybody
in their truck 101st airborne when I was
at the hundred first Airborne Division
me and my buddies were at South Campus
doing the MFO mission and we got sent
out on a damn crash rescue mission a bus
had been a civilian bus event sideswiped
by a [ __ ] tractor trailer carrying a
[ __ ] this bulldozer and the bulldozer
blade went down and it [ __ ] killed a
bunch of people inside the tractor it's
inside that bus it was out in the middle
of Sinai desert was darkest [ __ ] no
street lights or anything were there
with flashlights and we're going through
the crash system at which we were taking
turns going and they're pulling dead
people out there's about 17 of them I
think one of them was this hot girl that
from Israel that's pulled out of X
anxious yeah I didn't see the head the
head was gone but the [ __ ] hurt her
body head body was awesome bless Sarge
ah I saw her ID was hurt because it was
in it was all their idea was on the body
later on [ __ ] yeah later on my boy
[ __ ] her fluids isn't there
hey Bros who's your girlfriend [ __ ]
through this you calculate through me
the damn plastic bag and [ __ ] there
was the hair you just look like a damn
[ __ ] crushed [ __ ] skull with it
was in that clear plastic bag look like
a wig with a bunch of teeth and [ __ ]
ball on it yes sir so I was like you
guys are [ __ ] [ __ ] then I had to
ride in the back of the damn truck with
all the body bags why'd they make you
right back there what you keep from
falling out no it's just random ok came
from all fallen out at second hey miss
run right out of a horror movie but
that's just with that was the Job
Description
I mean I will say this job is great it
seems fucked-up and insensitive but
we've kind of talked about this on the
show before it's just paramedic works
well paramedics know what I'm saying
to that no I was talking about like them
throwing you the head and everything
yeah sometimes in situations like that
that are just so like [ __ ] up that
they're almost like surreal well you
almost kind of have to like revert to
humor because yeah yeah we're now the
[ __ ] else are gonna deal with it we were
kind of laughing about it you know what
I mean there's no other way but that's
what I mean that's why I don't get
offended by it here's the thing friend
of mine I grew up with [ __ ] you know
he runs a whole paramedic company whole
company of paramedics and in Detroit
Michael yeah Michael was one of my best
friends we went to high school together
when I was in Detroit and we've known
each other forever softest butter he did
that same job yeah you did that same job
and just it's just being around dead you
have to detach yeah it's just being
around dead people and it's not that bad
yeah once you get used to it yeah well
you don't just think about in a
particular way because you have to deal
with it it's your job they are not there
that's what you're not doing
domine was not them anymore you see you
just have to think of right like
it's just the remains I would probably
do the same it's just the remains and
like I said I can see why like I said I
can I can see why people complain and I
think I mentioned this on the last year
or the one before where every now and
then I'll get a complaint it's like oh
you guys are making jokes about
blah-dee-blah
like about a true-crime case yeah
seriously you can't it's not so much not
taking it seriously it's just that some
things in life are just like so horrific
that you have to like joke about it to
like distance yourself from just because
it's like it's so horrible you have to
back off of this [ __ ] yeah and look at
it look at it from a higher dimensional
plane you gotta we're all gonna die yeah
none of us are getting out hopefully
none of us in a horrible way like that
yeah none of us are getting out of this
[ __ ] alive okay eventually we all die
it's just a part of life yeah some
people are taken out too early some
people went really badly these little
kids tortured by these [ __ ] maniacs
I would kill that [ __ ] if I
could well yeah I know most people but
those people that died up in that bus
even though that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
gruesome and the [ __ ] smell of it and
everything it was an accident
there wasn't any malice behind it yeah
yeah I mean and hopefully most of them
didn't suffer I mean I would hope the
injuries it looked like he was instant I
don't know and that particularly our the
most her head was leaned up against the
window and that [ __ ] blade went down
that window yeah that's why it took her
head it stick around it didn't really
take it off it crushed it off or smashed
it off you know so she she was asleep
didn't know what hit her I think we can
I hope she didn't I think she was asleep
with her head up against yes yeah okay
well that's it that's the only thing you
can hope is just that anxious they
didn't know yeah I hope they didn't know
but yeah so all right so the cops show
up now they kind of like the other
people said well Lenore said some weird
[ __ ] about oh he's going upstairs to
kill himself and stuff and she said oh I
was just kidding which you know that's
kind of like the thing that people say
when they say some [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
they get in trouble for it yeah they're
like yeah I was just joking like
so I kind of feel like she did that so
they find George Reeves he's upstairs
he's on his bed he has there's a Luger
between his feet like laying on the
floor between his feet and there's a
bullet hole in his head it looks as
though he had been sitting on his bed
and just put the gun on the side of his
head and shot himself however there were
some other mitigating circumstances that
made people over the years believe that
maybe somebody else was involved one of
these things was the presence of I
believe five other bullet holes in
various walls around the room now
doesn't mean anything which that it
might not yeah might not sounds like he
might have been a kind of guy to just
shoot at a damn wall I mean Elvis used
to do it all a damn time a TV Wow I
accidentally touched one off when I was
a little kid did a little kid but you
know I guess I was in my 20s after I got
out of the Army accidentally touched off
a [ __ ] 45 round out of a 1911 [ __ ]
what did you hit it just hit the damn
wall I was good thing no one was
standing there I was quit drawn you know
I mean I had my headphones on I was
jamming out to [ __ ] a metal bit you
know I mean and I forgot that I'd
accidentally reloaded it and [ __ ] you
know was jamming out and picked it up
and [ __ ] with pointed at the damn
little birdie in the damn picture oh and
touched one off in the wall I was
probably this is why I don't not to
sneak up on you yeah I was young yeah I
mean I was young no well what the deal
was like since I had my headphones on
when I wrapped that slide I didn't hear
around to go under the chamber yeah yeah
I mean he's you're I forgot that I
popped the magazine into it you know you
know [ __ ] happens in blue that bird away
though bird at a damn picture shot right
through the glass
that was Mississippi [ __ ] you know
that's how that [ __ ] happens so okay so
even though so George Reeves death was
initially considered a suicide however
several people including his mother said
that he would never do that and so they
started hiring other lawyers private
investigators stuff like that to prove
that he had been murdered because there
were several other people in the house
at the time it should be noted that the
police had not checked
George Reese's fingers for residue to
see if he pulled the trigger
they didn't count the number of bullets
that remained in the gun didn't count it
no they apparently did not okay like I
said these guys were [ __ ] up back then
the residue on the hands that's all
[ __ ] they can never really find that
anyway very rare yeah there weren't I as
far as I know there weren't like any
powder burns or anything like that well
you don't get powder burns some [ __ ]
yes so I don't know if you guys have
seen the movie there's a really good
movie um called Hollywood land I think I
saw it in the theater Ben Affleck plays
George Reeves of all people but it's
actually like a really good movie it's
kind of like because it's a movie it's
going into like maybe it was like a
conspiracy and maybe likes me because
there were like some people that would
have wanted him dead presumably this one
I'm not super sure it does seem like
this is 60 yeah good I believe it was or
1959 1915 okay um but some people have
speculated that his fiancee
Lenore might have shot him which doesn't
seem that far-fetched to me because from
everyone that knew her she did seem like
a little bit of a crazy person and it
might have been the case that even
though they were engaged he was kind
like maybe wanting to break stuff off
and maybe there was some kind of
argument that night maybe there was some
kind of [ __ ] going on and she had like
shot up and stuff um I'm not really sure
about this one I kind of feel like it
could go either way like Phyllis Coates
um I saw a documentary about this they
did a [ __ ] do you remember that show I
can't remember what the name of it was
mysteries and scandals maybe and that
guy AJ Benza that used to host it that
was like they made him look like a
gangster or something and he talked like
a gangster I think it was on A&E or
something and he's our show about this
and they were talking to Phyllis Coates
who played Lois Lane on the Superman
show and she was like she just like did
not believe she was like I don't think
he would have killed himself because yes
he didn't like playing the Superman role
yes he was bummed out about it but we
were talking about like doing like he
had written a script like for a sci-fi
movie and he was talking to me about it
and we were talking about like finding
funding for it and he was like really
excited so she didn't think that he
would have killed himself just because
they had something to look forward to
now like I said that does not literally
mean yeah I mean if he was drunk you're
not thinking straight when you're
drawing it some at the P the moment yeah
and it's like if you're depressed about
others [ __ ] because like I said he was
um you know reportedly not happy about
having to play Superman and he was even
like bummed out about his career wasn't
going the way he wanted it to go so he
might have like just drunk too much that
night well then thought well I can tell
you one thing is that rich was rich
before he killed himself
was making plans yeah yeah yeah yeah
well they would do this that it doesn't
mean anything that's not the moment it's
it's um takes over you're drinking it
yeah I think we're drinking is involved
yeah it's a damn it it doesn't have
anything to do with like future plans or
anything like that it's just how you
feel in a bad moment like I said I've
been really drunk and like thought about
like [ __ ] up [ __ ] that you know we
should
something that we all agree we all
agreed that [ __ ] rich [ __ ] would
have regretted that [ __ ] yeah have you
been around yeah rajen regret he'd be
like oh [ __ ] that was dumb yeah so we
did it we actually didn't take it that
seriously or than in terms of like the
meaning behind it yeah they take it
seriously because there's a more like
accident like I said I hate to say it in
a way it is almost like an accident
because when you're that inebriated and
if you already like I'm not saying you
have to be like you know clinically
depressed or anything like that but if
you already have some like
disappointments in your life you already
have some like [ __ ] where it's like oh I
wish things had gone like this that in
the other and then you get like super
[ __ ] up and you get like you know
maybe get a fight with somebody or get
something like that it's like it's very
very easy rich would have been like [ __ ]
why did I do that yeah it's very very
easy to be like well you know nothing
like I wanted is ever gonna happen like
you know it's it's easy to get like that
if you already have that frame of mind
yes so I don't know if I want to
attribute this to murder or not it's
possible I mean he did have people like
and some people said well he was having
an affair with Tony Maddox maybe her
husband like had him bumped off even
though I think the husband knew about it
because they had an affair for like 10
years as far as I know yeah and I think
he knew about it yeah and didn't say
anything because I think he was just
kind of like that's how [ __ ] goes it's
George Reeves it's Superman go sleep
with Superman that's all right yeah I
guess it is like so I guess he wasn't
bothered by it but some people have
speculated that maybe he like didn't
like it and he was like or maybe she
hired somebody to do it because she had
because he had dumped her Tony Merrick
Mannix and was you know marrying this
other chick so maybe she was like hey go
bump that dude off because I don't want
to see like some other woman marrying
him which is possible I think they're
making too much of it based on my
personal experience with dudes that
[ __ ] off themselves in the heat of
the moment he was pissed off
at that time not feeling good plugged
himself and [ __ ] along really he
would have regretted it but he's
probably [ __ ] drinking I'm kind of
leaning try what it was
I'm count because like I said a lot of
people have said that plug himself or
the Finance pistol [ __ ] po8 Luger dad
probably using the old original load to
kill yourself that's the one to do it
way that was a [ __ ] classy pistol I
know a lot of what's that
that's the [ __ ] classy pissed what I
thought I shoot that old retro
9-millimeter load that I think was 88
grand bullet [ __ ] routed no wasn't
even pointed it back then it was just
rounded like a little 9-millimeter
Makarov round it's just you guys don't
know what I'm talking about yes like
it's a lady it's like a little I [ __ ]
love I love classic firearms I like the
new firearms but he does he watch that
what's that channel you watch all the
time that's a guy that works at that
auction house oh [ __ ] [ __ ] forgotten
weapons forgotten weapon yeah yeah I
like that his voice his voice is kind of
soothing he's involved he's actually he
works with a company that [ __ ] is
like an auctioning house for course an
auction house guys yeah but can I forgot
his name but because I'm drunk right now
but I'd normally be he's just a cool
dude he knows he's a young guy sits
there and he talks very like yeah type
of thing he talks about all the history
they don't even care about guns really
but it's like it's interesting just
hearing him like talk about this yeah if
you want to guys if you want if you want
a good education subscribe to [ __ ]
forgotten weapons on YouTube yeah yeah
it's yeah it's a good it's a decent
channel yeah yeah I'll tell you
everything where it began even [ __ ]
he'll even he even did one on the mac-10
that was Crossley's weapon was his
official official weapon from [ __ ]
escaped from New York yeah I had one I
had an Ingram mac-10
not a Cobra but in an Ingram like a nine
millimeter one not a 45 but not really a
good weapon but [ __ ] cool just cool
it was just cool but not good because
those are two completely different two
completely different they're not very
cool now what I'm thinking about is
same with everything cars Jannik yeah
who pees right there I mean there's a
big difference between cool and good
good
well there was a reason why mac-10 was
so we're in movies because they just
[ __ ] looked cool well yeah and that's
another thing it's just because
something looks good doesn't mean like
effectively yeah but yeah so the George
Reeves case even though I kind of feel
like there's and you know I'm not saying
that it's not possible that he was
murdered and I'm not saying that it's
not possible that his fiancee Leonora
lemon wasn't responsible for that [ __ ]
she could have shot him sure um I kind
of feel like this was a situation where
everyone was there everyone's drinking
he drank too much and then started like
dwelling on [ __ ] that he was upset about
and I said man [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and then he just did it without thinking
about I think this way I kind of feel
like maybe that's what happened I mean
like I said I know everybody likes to
like add all this [ __ ] [ __ ] to make
[ __ ] more mysterious and stuff but I do
it's usually dumb [ __ ] that's the truth
it is sadly enough and it's it it's sad
because it seems like people got really
upset because you know the Superman show
was like really popular with kids and
everything and then the big headline in
the newspaper is like the next day was
like Superman commits suicide or some
whatever the [ __ ] they said and can you
imagine like being a little kid and that
was like your idol Superman he's
supposed to be like a mean to bullets
and stuff like that and he [ __ ] shot
himself in the head can you imagine so
it's like I can see why stories about
maybe somebody else killed him kind of
maybe came to the fore because no one
wants to believe that Superman I can
just got depressed and blew his head off
yeah you know what I mean
that's a bad situation I mean but I'm
not saying I you know I'm leaning toward
that's what happened like I said before
my tell the audience I've been in that
situation of no guys that did it they've
done that it's an accident they actually
didn't mean it they were in a moment of
weakness
they were [ __ ] higher they were
drinking and they
a stupid [ __ ] decision based upon a
feeling they had at that particular
moment yeah 10 minutes later they would
have [ __ ] gone out lying you do that
because like I said when you're drunk
enough yeah dumb [ __ ] seems like a good
idea yeah that's what happens and if
you're inclined to depression or if
you're inclined to like self-pity or
something like that then it's very easy
to be like get super drunk can be like
well no one's ever gonna love me
nothing's ever gonna work out and to
just do that in the heat of that without
really thinking about it because you're
not thinking about long-term consequence
well rich did it not only because of
that but also because the girlfriend was
right there and he was trying to
grandstand yeah so ego was also in there
yeah I will pull the trigger and he did
but my [ __ ] was drunk what the
[ __ ] are you doing dude put the [ __ ]
gun yeah dumbass
it's kind of sad yeah but I got his [ __ ]
though I got punk I got some his [ __ ] to
this day I got pictures up yeah took
that [ __ ] off the wall his brother said
good take it his brother came and we
[ __ ] sit there and Chuck and divvied
up all the [ __ ] and his brother took his
job after that cuz he mean how well he
was a maintenance man and he was a
maintenance man [ __ ] for a big
building and come on Commonwealth F in
downtown Detroit Boston yeah so he was
the me so he got free rent and then
$1,000 a month
damn I'll take that [ __ ] jet ass
building he's like he was maybe 50 and
tie on it and golf dude with these you
know old-school goth dude with these
[ __ ] hot goth chicks in their 20s
they're they're all junkies they're
wrong hanger so they're all job guys
drugs whoa once the Internet
not us but once they get into that
junkie world it's junkion junkie see so
well because you're always looking for
your little brother Jeff so he was
heaving at that so he was like you know
the Brad Pitt of the [ __ ] Gulf junkie
world at that time yeah you know I meant
he had everything gone for him he had to
go fix sinks and [ __ ] fix [ __ ] here
and there but
you know free rent $1,000 a month [ __ ] I
would do yeah and the girl the girl he
was living with in the in that [ __ ]
apartment she was hot cops are talking
about fighting over the damn volume of
the television dumbass every now and
then
yeah little [ __ ] just pisses you off
yeah I get that I get it
and he wasn't to answer anybody's
question I think he wasn't a shooting
junkie he was a snorting jockey so I
didn't know not so many of those yeah I
didn't know he was hiding it from ya
though I didn't go hang out with him all
the time
but I've known him perfectly I do feel
like I mean he hit it I just thought he
was a fireman addicts are like Fitz
that's kind of like a hard thing to hide
but it's it's only a hard thing to hide
if you're like injecting this [ __ ] he
wasn't a [ __ ] he was snorting huh he was
snorting well man gonna hide that longer
only thing that's stuck out to me is
that goddamn ass do can drink a lot of
[ __ ] booze yeah but a lot of people
can he could drink a whole [ __ ] fifth
and remain [ __ ] so my brother could
and he took a drink man holy crap okay
well he was like maybe he could drink a
whole [ __ ] fifth and remain [ __ ]
coherent and [ __ ] he'd have women
hanging all over him and then the
[ __ ] would [ __ ] him nod off a
little bit then he wake back up and I
don't know what you know I was young at
that time young and naive I couldn't see
it well it's not like we hang out with a
lot of drug addict no it's not like I
really know well if we do we don't know
which won't what well that's what I mean
if they're if we are hanging out with
drug addicts yeah good they're good
enough at it that we don't know this
because they just seemed normal
well nowadays nowadays what they're
taking doesn't [ __ ] [ __ ] him up as
bad yeah it doesn't mess you up in the
sense heroin mess yep pretty bad yeah I
do feel like heroin addicts just kind of
sleep a lot yeah they're not they're not
out which maybe contributes to them I
feel like heroin addicts either died
really young or they live forever
it was a NIC really good forever rich
was like that he's like a vampire
I didn't realize
like in his 50s I was still a man I was
still in my 20s at that time and I
thought he was about my age see look at
ya like Nick Cave or Iggy Pop you know
like that it's like you know they look
like older but they don't look like
they're adults they are 50 oh that
[ __ ] said damn I'm 50 now but
you know but then there's a lot of
heroin addicts that died in their 20s
yeah but the ones that survived it and
what kind of get over it and don't
really do it anymore I feel like it kind
of like preserved he knew a lot of
famous people too you know I can do this
he knew [ __ ] Steven Tyler from
Aerosmith and all of it because they
were the old Boston bands yeah he knew
all those people that's crazy
yeah but yeah so Steven was in that [ __ ]
too for a while
yeah everybody knows yeah well I think
everybody was at that time period like
everybody that was in the music scene
was kind of like a heroin addict or
whatever so in the next case I want to
talk about it's the very famous case Bob
Crane now several people have requested
that we do a show on this and I don't
want to do this I read about Bob Crane
and one of my faceless villains volumes
if you don't know who Bob Crane is that
was the dude from Hogan's Heroes
Hogan's here who's kind of good-looking
guy he was a good-looking guy yeah kind
of look like Robert Conrad to me
yeah dad there wait now that you're
questioning it but he kind of came
across as a good guy but turns out this
[ __ ] was like he was you wanted
to keep him away from your wife he'd
make porn in a heartbeat with your wife
we're gonna get to that he was a porn
aficionado yeah let's call it that and
no judgment
yeah judgment um as far as I know and
according to everyone that knew him yes
he made a lot of porn in a day before
anyone really did that yeah um but he
was ahead of the curve apparently it was
all consensual like I don't think like
he had to like rape anyone or drug
anyone or anything like that according
to his family and his friends and
everyone that knew him
they said everybody that I don't know
there there's kind of some gray area
there because he did like record some
sexual encounters with women and I'm not
entirely sure whether they knew that
that was happening or not which if they
didn't know then that's not cool don't
do that but um I don't know like
according to his friends and family they
said it was all consensual and now was
he in the porn you can see it was him
yes you could yeah I guess he was nice
for his own he wasn't selling something
I think he wishes it was just for his
own edification and I believe to like
trade with a few of his other porn
aficionado Franken's I think it was just
kind of like on the DL it wasn't like
nowadays like I'm gonna make some porn
by getting the one but it's in the whole
[ __ ] world right yeah
it wasn't like that it was like back in
the you had to have like camera
equipment I didn't really know the
details I thought maybe he was selling
it I don't think he was I think it was
just like circulating among a few
friends I'm like I said there are some
issues I don't know if every other girl
and he was getting were they porn stars
so they just random women that he was
paying to being a porn star that's what
I'm saying I don't know if they were
porn stars or if they was just women
that he was sleeping with it were either
okay with him recording on okay and
other people seeing it or didn't know
recording so it's like I don't know
there's no gray area there so like I
said he might be like I said if
everybody knew what was going on that's
cool you do you if some of the people
did not know what's going on that is not
cool yeah you know I'm not saying that
it's cool that he got murdered because
right but that's still like yeah what
happened tell us so let's go back to
June 29th 1878 this was a Scottsdale
Arizona at a hotel room so one of the
apartment complexes in Scottsdale
Arizona somebody calls and this is a
woman who is an actress and who was a
friend of Bob cranes and who had gone
into his apartment or you know was had
an appointment with him that day and he
hadn't turned up they were supposed to
have lunch together they were gonna play
together whatever so the cops go into
the apartment and find a dead body now
the body is he was at the time 49 years
old they find him lying
is bed with two big gashes above his
left ear and an electrical cord tied
around his neck damn now at the time
like the way he was laying this is like
messed up but the way he was laying like
the one side of his face that you can
see was like so [ __ ] up like somebody
had clearly like beat the [ __ ] out of
this person's face like they were not
recognizable hmm so the cops didn't know
who it was at first you know there was
blood all over the room the [ __ ]
pillow was red there was like blood all
over the walls everything as there would
be if you would like beaten someone to
death as he apparently had been so since
they found out that this apartment was
rented to the windmill dinner theater
they called them up and said hey um
somebody that's in one of your rented
apartments is dead so you want to come
over here and check out who this is so
the manager of the theater ed Beck comes
over and he said later on that he's like
okay well when I first saw the body at
first he's like I had no idea who it was
because it was just like a red mush
essentially but when they turned the
head around he immediately recognized
him as Bob Crane hmm now at this point
this is the 1978 Bob cranes um stardom
was kind of behind him I mean obviously
everyone knows him from Hogan's Heroes
which made him a huge star like all
across the United States
I don't know how popular it was around
the world I don't know if they showed
that show in other countries or whatever
but in the u.s. he was a household name
everybody knew who he was but by 1978 it
kind of seemed like he had degenerated
in his career a little bit to the point
where he was now doing like dinner
theater tours like yeah in other words
he was like below Hollywood Squares
level yeah yeah which that's kind of sad
to say but yeah once you were to like
touring with dinner theater yeah you
were down at about you couldn't even be
on Hollywood Square for you young people
even who alley with squares is a game
show ya had Hollywood Squares was a fun
[ __ ] game she liked watching hi yeah
well because half of its celebrities on
there were drunk ashamed drunk as [ __ ]
and they were [ __ ] being hired what
was gay dude gay dude there was Paul and
Paul win it was a center square yeah
they made him center square because he
was the funny he was the funniest one
that he was other [ __ ] made Hollywood
Squares Paulin was a [ __ ] King he's a
[ __ ] King do his whole [ __ ] legend
yeah he was a legend also trivia yeah if
you guys saw the kids movie Charlotte's
Web Paul Lynde did the voice of the rat
I mean yeah if you guys saw Charlotte's
Web you know I'm talking about
um but yeah so yeah he was always the
center square and he was lady he's
clearly the house that's gay history for
you people yeah Paul and that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] it was the king of
all gays it's funny though because back
in they didn't like I was a kid when
that show was on and I used to always
watch I well I love to Hollywood Squares
but it's like you didn't really think of
it as like I don't know you didn't
really think of it as gay you just
thought didn't matter Beca it didn't
matter
that's like it wasn't really something
that bothered you in the journey or
something like that is just the way that
dude is is it was cool back then see now
it's not cool because they got to make
some kind of statement about it as if it
is the thing back then it wasn't a thing
it was just [ __ ] Paul it was a thing
but you couldn't but that's this way
that's just what it was but everybody
knew everybody [ __ ] dude everybody
well I don't know if everybody knew I
think everybody with half a [ __ ]
brain yeah
although I'll tell you one thing though
[ __ ] a lot of women didn't understand
that Liberace was gay that blows my
[ __ ] mind
showers and even Evel Knievel knew
Liberace was gay everybody
yeah well like I said back in the old
days I I kind of feel like there was a
disconnect between yeah Hollywood and
your average person that was watching
this [ __ ] few people who don't
understand anything you're too young to
understand Thanks and [ __ ] have kind
of weird [ __ ] conceptions about the
way people are
Evel Knievel was the [ __ ] man of all
men this [ __ ] was alpha as [ __ ]
I mean this dude was so manly he was
[ __ ] criminal really he was okay
Knievel [ __ ] loved Liberace he seemed
like a cool dude and loved he said
Liberace was the master of all [ __ ]
pudding honestly I mean Evel Knievel
like from everything I've seen like
interviews and he kind of seemed like a
little bit of a dick
gotta say [ __ ] was a dick anyway
he was he was a dick but he could back
it up yeah he could do all that [ __ ] he
but personality-wise he was kind of a
dick he's played his own line Liberace
always seemed like a lovely person he
loved Liberace I can see that he
incorporated many of Liberace's [ __ ]
stick into foam tape he's good on yes
you said that [ __ ] you know that
Liberace was one of the bravest men he
ever knew and what he was talking about
us you know
he knew that bride she was gay and he
was like not yeah yeah secret about not
really secret although I think that
people of the time were not really ready
to embrace that they would kind of like
say it was other stuff it's like oh well
he's just um flamboyant you gotta
understand something man [ __ ] Evel
Knievel was [ __ ] brave and he
understood the [ __ ] that he wasn't
brave enough to just jump on a dick the
way [ __ ] Liberace was well like I said
it's like in a day when everyone thinks
that you're a monster or everyone thinks
that you're like subhuman yeah it's very
brave to just come out and be like hey
this is me yeah you know what I mean and
it was obvious to people who'd knew what
the deal was but yeah yeah so you know
what I mean it's you know everyone's
gonna think you're brave if you like
jump over a canyon or whatever obviously
that's like it's not controversial so I
can see what what he's getting it I
believe you don't believe me look back
in history just go look up [ __ ] laughter
you like Evel Knievel more yeah you
didn't know that I didn't actually know
oh no Liberace Liberace [ __ ] was
influenced by two men in terms of on the
show business side and that was Elvis
and Liberace
yeah and he's blaming Evel Knievel was
influenced by Elvis and Liberace yeah he
said they were the two greatest showman
of all times
and then he went on about Liberace City
you know he would love dough he went to
go see Liberace shows you know it's
funny I first saw a Liberace I think on
the Muppet Show yeah isn't that funny
like it Liberace was kind of like the
piano version of Bob Ross he'd started
talking to the [ __ ] cat and you start
mesmerizing [ __ ]
you'd I mean that and he had a huge
[ __ ] a huge sea of female fans
usually older women they just [ __ ]
loved it well and he said he could not
come out because he didn't want to break
all those hearts that's like a watch he
said he said he wanted them to have some
hope because [ __ ] everybody else [ __ ]
was gay everybody else knew that my leg
was gay yeah of course but like I said
well the thing about Liberace and about
Bob Ross and everything like that the
reason everybody loves them is not just
because but it's like the thing about it
is in action with the audience yeah and
it's like well they have like an empathy
like a sympathetic kind of thing and
like people relate to that right and
that's what can evil one
yeah evil wanted it to where every wish
he only pulled off partially cuz like I
said I think his personality was very he
wasn't a people person he was like a
gladiator okay yeah and he wanted people
to be there with him as he did those
death-defying [ __ ] jumps he wanted
you to feel it your life was at risk
- yeah and [ __ ] and and he he was
trying to he was trying to channel
Liberace and Elvis yeah at the same time
to get that he wanted you to be jumping
with him yeah not just sitting there
[ __ ] you know what I mean Pat Sibley
can passively [ __ ] cheering for his
death well because he knew that most
people were there and [ __ ] see him
die well you already have that kind of
like and it's the same thing with people
that watch NASCAR people to watch
anything like that yeah it's like in a
way it's like weird because you kind of
want to see like horrible accidents and
you want to see people get killed but
then like if you see people get killed
like you feel really bad because look
I'm from Daytona Beach which I don't
know if you guys from overseas know but
that
like Nascar central I grew up only a
couple of miles I was born in a hospital
across the street from the Daytona
International Speedway yeah so when Dale
Earnhardt got killed at one of the races
and I remember when it was because I
don't follow that stuff but it was kind
of like this big huge it's like
everybody wants that to happen but
within what it does happen they all feel
yeah you know what I mean
so it's kind of that kind of thing I
came from a generation of boys growing
up in the 70s where Evel Knievel was the
ultimate male we we had all water to be
stuntmen I think I've talked about that
on yeah where I [ __ ] stole my dad's
[ __ ] motorcycle helmet time to
[ __ ] Beach down mom's [ __ ] rubber
dish gloves are gonna jump off a dime
top of the house cuz I want to be a
stuntman yeah Evel Knievel
we had an Evel Knievel toys my brother
had them yeah my brother I have two
brothers and how it kind of goes full
circle with me me and Elvis and Billy
Idol and it [ __ ] goes around with
Elvis and Billy Idol and Liberace
somehow it's all on the cross me selling
that it's all within the cross was fear
in some weird way because cross will
play - Elvis - that's what I mean
yeah it's in the crustle sphere like
actually exactly yeah it's a yin-yang
thing it's the male and female forces
within men that's what they're talking
that's what that's what [ __ ] Evel
Knievel was talking see you admit that
there are female horses oh yeah there
were female forces of course yeah oh no
no of course there's Sun and Sun and
Moon and creation dump [ __ ] is that some
[ __ ] that gets assigned to like female
[ __ ] I'm just kind of like why is this
female well there's a female destroyer
- you don't especially if you look at
[ __ ] you look at [ __ ] Indian
philosophies and religions you -
Macaulay yeah Kali
well it makes me resent what females are
creators right as in Bakke
more people right so it would make sense
that they would also be destroyers right
we gotta get back we gotta give so yeah
we're stretching this [ __ ] out too far
the audience is like what the [ __ ] these
two top well I kept I kept telling him
he's just kind of like before we started
the second half I was like well I have
two more cases we gotta talk about Bob
Crane we got a second oh yes she's like
trying to [ __ ] up and I was like yeah he
was gonna make some pancakes what some
pancakes - okay but I said well we'll
hurry it up if you don't go off on a
bunch of tangents and then he goes off
but this show is about tangent ever we
do the tangent stuff I thought that once
we started the sidetracks thing that we
get all our digits out like we would get
all our tangents out of the way yeah but
then like when I was thinking about I
was like yeah that probably won't happen
it's a show because if I think about
stuff if I talk about stuff that's not
related to what we talked about the
tangent show yeah then we'll probably
just go off on tangents then the show is
a show we're putting on a show yeah
whatever yeah shits gonna come out so
yeah Bob Crane yeah okay so Bob Crane
they find him dead in a in an apartment
or hotel room that was like rented by
the dinner theater that he was working
for he was actually working on a play
called the beginner called beginner's
luck now like I said at this stage he
had been like Hogan's Heroes was many
years in the past he was still
well-known for that but after that had
been canceled
he had kind of like gone on the dinner
theater circuit which like I said no
judgment but I'm just saying it's kind
of like at that time people were like
movies and then like TV was like a step
down and then like dinner theater was
like two or three steps down you know I
mean it would still work though you were
still working but everybody kind of
looked askance at it so he's on the
dinner theater circuit he's touring
around the country with his play called
beginner's luck and apparently this
dinner theater had rented you know all
these apartments hotel rooms whatever
for their actors to stay in and that's
the one he was staying at in Scottsdale
Arizona and he got murdered in it
so as we said before like after he got
killed he kind of had like a pretty um
you know upstanding reputation before
his murder after he was murdered all
this [ __ ] came out about all this [ __ ]
that he had been up to while he was like
you know on the down-low like I said he
was let's call it an early adopter oh
I'm just saying no judgement yeah no
gentleman he was an early adopter of you
know porn technology yeah that's cause
that so technology selfie porn yeah
essentially what he was doing and like I
said this wasn't like nowadays where you
can just film [ __ ] with your phone this
was like when you had to go out and like
specifically buys and camera equipment
which is thousands of thousands of
dollars worth of camera equipment to
like buy some you know fancy [ __ ] to
film yourself having sex with various
women so this was something that he was
very into now a lot of his family said
that he was also into you know kind of
filming other things too like family
moments and whatnot cuz he was he'd
married his high school sweetheart
they'd a couple of kids at this stage
and I don't think they knew about any of
this but um you know like I said after
he died it kind of came out that he had
been like I said there there's a
question of like whether a lot of it was
consensual or not but apparently he
didn't have a problem like it would hard
for it to be when I'm in central because
you couldn't hide these cameras so they
must have known I mean it required a
bunch of [ __ ] equipment I mean you
could have put them in a closet
technically yeah but it made noise when
it ran it's not like you could just like
put a little tiny [ __ ] cell phone
it was Hardware back then it was harder
to like yeah I got a feeling they knew
so I do feel like you know maybe a lot
of these people knew maybe they weren't
were okay with being filmed maybe not I
don't really know but he was into
filming himself having sex with women
and either just keeping it for his own
use or trading it among friends or like
other aficionados or whatever so he like
I said he was an early adopter important
technology so I call it a technology
that's [ __ ] funny well I'm just
saying and I have to say too that porn
you know deride it all you want but it's
a universal it goes back to the Great
Pyramid is that a universal but porn
also tends to be you know the whole porn
industry tends to be very early adopters
of new technology I mean look at like
when I get VHS first came out for
example before the big movie is movie
studios even yeah it's like shiny wind
of like what what was going I was like I
don't even born was on to that [ __ ] porn
girls are [ __ ] live camera that's it
they're streaming it they stream the
[ __ ] live cam okay
that's we literally Hollywood's gonna
have to do this [ __ ] now I don't think
those theatres are coming back they're
already doing it it's gonna be fun they
were saying it today remember I called
that [ __ ] they're gonna start well I
told you yesterday before I got an email
from AMC Theaters and they are already
streaming several of their movies yeah
that we're either in the theaters or hit
just left the theaters and it is we'll
watch them remind you tomorrow we'll
watch what they're what they're
streaming well it's a we've already seen
some of them look like some of us like
birds of prey we've already seen that
like Invisible Man we're seeing that
even though it was very good and I
wouldn't mind seeing that again but it's
like we've already seen some of the [ __ ]
like some of the movies that they're
showing I haven't seen so Hollywood is
gonna adopt a Netflix model it doesn't
have a choice I do feel as well I like I
said if it be cool if they could have
like the theaters as an option if you
wanted that but it's like it would be
cool if they could release stuff to the
theater and streaming at the same time
so you can have an option hey if you
want to go out and see it you can see it
but also if you want to watch it your
house is that if they did that what will
happen is is that they'll all take the
stream and Noah will go to there no one
would go today well you don't know that
because some people do like that won't
be enough like I like going to the
theater won't be enough to keep that
seat but they could have like
smaller theatres it could be more
they'll have less of Amul sure to
different places and they'll be less
than that but if people wanted to go out
because looking like in Orlando
specifically where we live you know
there's a theater called the Enzian
which is it's been there for like as
long as I can remember and it's like an
indie theatre so they don't show new
movies but they show like specialty
movies or stuff that doesn't get shown
here by like the big theaters they have
a whole cafe they have food that bla
they have yeah they bar them everything
like that so it's like it's kind of like
you can go out for the night you can see
either an old movie or like a new indie
movie or a documentary something you
wouldn't be able to see in a theater and
you can have a meal you can have wine
you can have a beer you can have
whatever and it's like a whole
experience once again we got sidetracked
well yeah I know well you know what I
try to tell you your job you're thinking
about painting and I would think about
pancake you go and get your eggs and
bacon and [ __ ] like that okay well yeah
you can do this my belly so yeah so
everybody kind of knew like I said
nobody knew his close friends knew at
the time but after he died like
everybody can I found out that he was
into all of this porn business and like
filming herself now it turned out that
he had let's call it a partner in crime
in the colloquial sense I'm not meaning
like crime in real sense name John Henry
carpenter this is not John Carpenter the
film director who has talked about this
is a different date entirely um he was a
video equipment sales person and he was
a friend of Bob cranes he was also a
friend of some of you older people may
know richard Dawson who was oh yeah yeah
family feud host he was also in running
man that dude was a dog he was all yeah
he was also in Hogan's Heroes yeah like
you know younger people might know
that's another dude you didn't want
around your wife
none of these do know yeah and he's
doing a great job in [ __ ] a running
man with Arnold Schwarzenegger but it
was very good I remember like I didn't
even know he was in Hogan's Heroes cuz
that was a little before my time but I
knew
from family feud because I used to watch
them that was a no-good series I saw it
was a little kid come don't come
you know after school yeah yeah on
reruns so I feel like Bob Crane even
though like a lot of people didn't know
about his proclivities like some people
that he worked with kind of knew what
was going on because he was kind of
known for being let's call it I don't
know he had like like sexual he he had
like a sexual appetite yeah his sexual
problems not like that he was a killing
but yet like he would he tended to have
affairs with his co-workers um you know
[ __ ] like that it didn't seem like
anything rapey outright but it did seem
like he was always kind of like very he
was very flirty and he was kind of like
always having affair good to call back
the dead dick slinger yeah that's a good
way of putting yeah so I do feel like
and he also had a tendency of like he
would go and sleep with women who
necessarily celebrities he would just
like go to other cities like if he was
working in other cities and he was sleep
with women he would take pictures of
them I don't know if it was consensual
or not and then he would like put them
in these um like scrapbooks yeah and be
like hey that's that chick from
Jacksonville remember that you know it's
be sensual I'm sure it was it he was a
celebrity so they according to his
friends it was yeah um I don't know he's
a celebrity there was no Janet back then
there was no and he was a good-looking
fella yeah but um so apparently at the
time that he was doing this I guess he
was working for Disney and he was doing
some Disney movies like I said they were
very concerned about their stars you
know images at the time and apparently
he was kind of doing this Disney movie
called super dad which is supposed to be
this like really wholesome family movie
or whatever and it was started kind of
getting around that he was like banging
all these women and like taking pictures
of them and like keeping this scrapbook
or whatever so he was kind of like
getting a bad reputation
so you know it I don't know it's his
family tend to think it's like yeah it
seemed like after it all came out it
seemed like oh he had this dark side and
everything like that the people who know
about but they're like well he was just
a very sexual person and very sexual
verse yeah and they're just kind of
making him look bad like I said if it
was all consensual then that's fine I'm
sure it was but you know there would've
been you know there to come after him
with [ __ ] courts and [ __ ] if he's
he's raping I'm just I'm saying I kind
of feel like there wasn't any rape and
you know as far as I know there were no
rape allegations he was celebrity there
was a lot of women that [ __ ] them you
know I mean easy to charm they were into
that you know I mean he was the kind of
guy who women as soon as his as soon as
the son turned 21 he took him to see
deep throat yeah you take your son to
see a portable [ __ ] something
that is kind of weird yeah I don't know
where the in the theater beaten off next
to each other I hope not dad I better
not because that would be where should
that be some weird [ __ ]
it's it's kind of weird taking your son
even if he's even if your son's an adult
it isn't how - we're taking your son so
oh yeah that's you I mean wouldn't fly
with me yeah imagine if you just ruin a
one-year-old son there's this far away
would you want to watch porn it's it's
kind of like how you don't ask me that
Lube I'm gonna dude so I don't know it's
kind of like you know when you watch
like a movie with your parents like say
you're just watching like a normal movie
with your parents and then like there's
like a sex scene and you forgot it was
in there and then you're all really
uncomfortable I kind of feel like it
would be that but like times a hundred
yeah so it's weird like I said no
judgment but I'm not judge it's weird
I'm not judging
yeah it's a little weird but that is
something that that he would do
evidently according to his son so um so
like I said his TV career was you know
Hogan's Heroes was long in the past he
was still kind of a star but at this
stage he was like on the dinner theater
circuit so he gets to Phenix era
he's touring with this [ __ ] play and
this was his second marriage at this
point he was kind of like heading toward
divorce he had been had some guest spots
on The Love Boat and [ __ ] like that
which like I said that was another thing
that was kind of like contributing to
you you not being in the a-list anymore
so now according to most people so he
had this friend John Henry carpenter
like I said not John Carpenter the
director I want to make that clear so
the two of them were friends and they
apparently made a lot of porn together
like in the sense that Carpenter would
film them or like they would share films
between them or whatever now there is
some there's there's some kind of like
controversy over what their relationship
was at this point like when Bob Crane
was killed because his son seems to
think that Carpenter was the one that
killed Bob Crane because he says that at
this point in Bob cranes life he was
kind of like thinking of turning his
[ __ ] around and he was kind of sick of
John Henry carpenter always hanging
around but he was he didn't really like
him particularly and he just kind of
wanted to like kind of take out the
trash sort of so there was kind of a
thing where he was like well I'm just
gonna confront him and tell him I don't
want to hang out with him anymore with
anything so I kind of feel like the son
feels like there was like this kind of
he calls it almost like a lover's spat
cuz they had been very close friends for
a long time and he was like I kind of
feel like they you know he maybe told
him off like hey I don't want to see you
anymore something like that and then
John Henry carpenter got pissed off and
beat him to death and that was who
killed him hmm but that's the thing like
I kind of tend toward that you know
outcome but it's like there weren't any
other suspects he's the kind of the main
suspect and I have to say that there's a
lot of circumstantial evidence pointing
to him although could it have been like
a husband
one of these girls that's what I mean
there's like so many other people that
could have been like yes I kind of feel
like Carpenter is the most likely
suspect cuz look they had been friends
for a long time they were in like he
filmed a lot of porn for him they like
they were very close
according to his son and a couple of
other people
Krane was sick of carpenter hanging
around like he saw him is kind of like a
leech or a hanger-on or something like
that and he was kind of like kind of
tired of him being it and he was gonna
confront him and tell him to like okay
because it could be because you gotta
understand you know crane would have
been this dude's ticket into these
taking pictures sure if crane goes that
boy's porno [ __ ] goes to you don't I
mean like his his ability did to watch
porn happen here I mean he might have
yeah voyeuristic kind of guy to where he
wants to watch people have sex
you must take picture yeah crane [ __ ]
walks out he won't be a patoot on his
own so there might have been some kind
of a fight there an argument broke out
and one thing led to another he probably
didn't plan on killing him but maybe he
did that's what I mean it's like okay so
they did at the time carpenter was the
main suspect
um they impounded his rental car which
was a Chrysler Cordoba okay no but they
think you know Ricardo montalbán shows
up old people know about we're talking
about right now another error but it's
like it's sad because it's like I'm not
that old but I still remember all this
the old Star Trek movies and [ __ ] for
Patrick two inches we've been watching
all those those old Star Trek movies are
[ __ ] awesome they're better than I
remember yeah yeah well like I said
Spock is my spirit animal yeah you're
talking about with [ __ ] you know Kirk
and Spock yeah
Star Trek 1 through 5 good check him out
man they're good although Spock wasn't
in them it's like it would have been I
don't think I would have bothered
watching this that's [ __ ] awesome
Spock is clearly literally boy [ __ ]
crazy that character he was the best
part of the series and as all the movies
sidetracked ya Nazca but yeah so
carpenter it seems like to me is the
most likely suspect in the sense that
even though some people said that yes
the night before the murder they had
apparently had dinner together him and
Bob Crane
now some people said they were arguing
however there are also witnesses that
said they were just having dinner like
normal people and it looked like they
were all chummy and everything like that
so there's some you know ambiguity there
now they did search carpenters rental
car and they found some blood in there
however it was like indeterminate like
what where it was what it came from like
you know what I mean they don't really
know like worried and it was a rental
car so hmm they didn't really have like
any way of proving anything so carpenter
did actually go to trial for the [ __ ]
but he was acquitted hmm now the case
was reopened in 2011 because apparently
somebody was that was going through like
some old like crime scene footage and
whatever like you know for the case
because this is a pretty high-profile
case right they found a photograph from
the old police files that seemed to show
not only the blood on the inside of
carpenters rental car but also what
appeared to be a fragment of brain
matter and so they introduced that to
like the district attorney and the
district attorney said okay well that's
kind of maybe enough they couldn't find
the actual piece of brain matter like in
evidence or anything apparently had been
lost or destroyed at some point but they
were like well the photograph is clear
enough that it looked like it was enough
that they could Bree up in the case so
they reopened the case in 2011 and I
believe they retried a carpenter at that
point however the DNA evidence because
like I said they still had a lot of the
evidence from the case they redid the
DNA evidence but the DNA that they could
recover from the rental car it was just
from all they could determine what was
unidentified male hmmm that's all they
could couldn't
continue anybody so it's like they
couldn't pin it on him now most people
do believe that Carpenter was probably
the most likely suspect even though I
have to say that they're pretty sure
that Bob Crane died from you know
blunt-force trauma to the head
now most people said and this has kind
of been repeated a lot like from varying
source of the years that he had been
beaten in the head with a camera tripod
um they're not sure if that's the case
yeah they're saying that they that a lot
of sources reported that because they
were trying to pin it on carpenter
saying oh well that's obviously what he
would have used because he was a
photographer but most of the
investigating officer said we don't know
what he was beaten with we couldn't tell
what it was you're saying the carpenter
is most likely but most the most likely
but most likely is not enough to get
ignited that's what I mean that had not
beyond a shadow of a doubt I don't know
so carpenter for you're out there it's
not enough well no no no he's dead no
he's dead yeah
he's not um he like I said he most
people think he was the most likely
suspect um some people have speculated
that maybe his ex-wife had something to
do with it because she was the only one
that got any monetary gain from his
death that maybe she hired somebody but
I'm likely you know yeah money is always
a good thing but it's like that's it's
kind of a long stretch to like hey I'd
get a million dollars to hey let's hire
somebody to kill that dude that's that's
two completely different things um
honestly I kind of feel like in this
situation obviously somebody killed him
it was somebody that he probably knew
because there was no sign of forced
entry you know what I mean when they
went in there it didn't look like
anything was disturbed otherwise so
somebody obviously came in that new head
and probably was carpenter I kind of
feel like it probably was his buddy
but they're fighting you know and
according to his son and several other
witnesses they said that Bob Crane was
kind of sick of carpenter hanging around
and he was kind of like wanting to get
out of that [ __ ] and he wanted to like
cut ties with him and so there would
have been a motive there but
like I said there's not enough evidence
they even had they had DNA from the car
that everything I do kind of feel like
he's probably the most likely suspect
but there is really no way of proving at
this point because he's dead now um so
that went back into the that's back in
time back in the seventies love Motel
area era you'll never be able to prove
the love love that's back when they had
damn [ __ ] [ __ ] when they call
carpet going up on the ceilings I love
it
carpets down walls and sound but yeah
you know indoor indoor [ __ ]
waterfalls and [ __ ] one of my favorite
things it's like I know this is another
tangent but one of my favorite things
we've mentioned the Dan Bell show before
where he usually does goes although but
he does other things too but there was
this one it was an abandoned love love
Motel like Hotel in the Poconos that's
what I was thinking of and it's
abandoned now but it is like a big thing
like in the 70s and stuff and he goes in
there and like films it and it's amazing
yeah [ __ ] couples would go there
amazing DS and they'd [ __ ] go to love
Motown as big social thing there'd be
swinging involved and you'd trade your
girlfriend with somebody else's your
partner wives and yeah just that's what
they do go figure
everybody has definitely transmitted
diseases back then yeah that was before
age yeah AIDS put a stop to that yeah
like yeah you can't just bang anything
that moves
yeah wife swapping alright so the last
case we're gonna talk about the infamous
case I've missed Natalie Wood yeah she
died when I was a little boy now if you
guys don't know like some some you
youngsters might not know that like
don't watch older movies and stuff she
got her started as a child actress she
was actually a former big breakout roles
with Miracle on 34th Street
she was the kid in that she was also in
West Side Story so she was in a bunch of
[ __ ] I think she had like three Oscar
nominations before she was 25 so she was
like a very prominent
child actress she was pretty yeah and
even like as a child actress directors
like really wanted to work with her
because even when before she was a
teenager she was known as one take
Natalie because what she would do is
that she would not only learn her part
but she would learn everyone's parts and
she would be like [ __ ] prepared for
the [ __ ] now her parents were actually
Russian immigrants her name was changed
from like a much more like a you know
Russian name so her mom was like a stage
mom and kind of wanted her to be the
breadwinner of the family so you know
how that goes so she was kind of like
pushing her to be in there are some like
[ __ ] up stories about apparently on
the set of I believe it was Miracle on
34th Street when she had a cry in one
scene Natalie Wood had to cry in one
scene apparently her mom like pulled her
off the set and like pulled the wings up
a butterfly like to get her to cry
because she did that she'd be upset
about it yeah so it's that kind of thing
but yeah um she was actually really
really successful from a very early age
now the thing about it though it's like
when she was growing up like I said she
was very prominent she was very she had
many Oscar nominations she was very
respected she dated Elvis Presley for a
time which they went into in the biopic
by a carpenter that we're watching at
the moment um you know she dated a lot
of famous people even when she was very
young
you know and she works with a lot of
famous directors now eventually she
ended up marrying Richard Wagner who
people from our era will know from heart
to heart he was in like a lot of [ __ ]
before that like he's quite famous but
that's where I knew him from yeah like
he'd he was in heart tired it was like a
detective show so they ended up marrying
and then they divorced but then they
ended up marrying again later on you
know everything yeah and that's when the
trouble started
so Natalie would when she was 43 years
old like I said she'd had a lot of
success when she was younger when she
got into her 40s as happens with many
actresses they were having a harder time
finding work she had been married to
Robert Wagner at one point in the past
and she had divorced him and a dated
other kind of high-profile people but
then ended up they ended up hooking back
up like 10 or 12 years like after their
divorce and getting married again
now Robert Wagner had a yacht called the
splendor and they often went out on it
when they were kind of trying to get
away from it all or whatever so it so
happened that around this time period in
1981 this actually happened
she and Robert Wagner as well as
Christopher Walken who was actually
starring with a in a movie with Robert
Wagner at the time they were all out on
the boat kind of partying or trying to
get away from everything so Natalie Wood
who was 43 at the time she ends up dead
her body is found floating off the coast
of Catalina Island and at first it
seemed like an accident like she had
just drowned it appeared from the
autopsy that she had died from drowning
however over the years some weird [ __ ]
has come to light that makes it seem
like maybe her death was not exactly I
remember when everybody's talking about
it
like I said 81 this huh yeah so what
ended up happening so the night that
this habit was Thanksgiving weekend of
1981 so they're all out on the boat they
take a sailing trip around Catalina
Island like I said it was Robert Wagner
Natalie Wood and it was Christopher
Walken who was working on a movie with
with Robert Wagner at the time and
what had happened okay so what they said
at the time they found her body like the
following morning and at first they
ruled the death an accident even though
it must be noted that when her body was
found she wasn't wearing like swimming
stuff she wasn't like a codon and like a
nightgown and like stuff that you
wouldn't necessarily be like swimming
around in did they say she was swimming
no they said what Robert Wagner said at
the time was that he and Christopher
Walken had been talking they'd all been
drinking they admitted that they had all
been out to dinner previously like the
night before and they were all kind of
pretty hammered and they'd all kind of
gone back to the boat and they were all
kind of like hanging out and she had
gone to bed early like at 10:00 or 10:30
or something and then when he went to
check on her when he went to bed she
wasn't there that's what he said
so gonna say she fell overboard that's
kind of like what the story was for a
long time and even like when they first
did the autopsy when they first did like
cause of death or like that they ruled
it an accidental drowning but a lot of
people were kind of skeptical even from
the beginning
um partially because even though it
appeared that the cause of death was
drowning she did seem to have some minor
bruising on her arms she also had an
abrasion on her left cheek although
these were fairly superficial it wasn't
kind of like you know it didn't look
like he was beating on or anything but
it just was something to like note so
for a long time it kind of stayed on the
death certificate that she had died just
by accidental drowning and most people
said well we were all kind of drunk that
night it's like maybe she tried to climb
on the dinghy like from the yacht which
was called the valiant and had somehow
like fallen off the boat and had drowned
even though it must be noted that
Natalie Wood was particularly terrified
of water
she could not swim and she had been
terrified of water her whole life most
sources say because when she was a kid
her mom had taken her to a psychic and
the psychic had told her one that she
would be a great beauty when she were up
and she would be famous which was true
and also that she should quote/unquote
be aware of dark water and everything's
true and ever since then she was like
really scared of water and her mom even
said everyone her family said she
couldn't swim as she didn't really like
water so a lot of people said well she
wouldn't have just gone out into the
dinghy on her own drunk cuz they were in
her regular clothes her nightgown and
like a coat and stuff they just thought
that was kind of weird so for a long
time there was like a lot of questions
surrounding this now it turned out that
many years later the guy who was like
the who was that hold on a second I lost
my voice so in 2001 though the guy who
was the captain of the yacht whose name
was Dennis daven now he said that even
though at the time that Natalie Wood had
turned up dead in 1981 he had
corroborated Wagner story he came out in
2011 and said you know there was some
[ __ ] I didn't tell people so he said
that not only had he I believe he had
taken Natalie to the shore like the
night before like in the dinghy because
her and what Robert Wagner had been
having a fight but he also kind of said
that I didn't tell you this before but
Robert Wagner and Christopher Walken
were also having an argument they said
like look before they went back out on
the yacht like the night that she
disappeared they had all been having
dinner at this place and apparently
someone that worked at this restaurant
where they were having dinner said that
one of them they don't know who it was
because they didn't see it through
either glass or a bar
against the wall like so apparently
there was like a big they were all like
inebriated and they were all having a
big argument
now most people speculate that the
argument was because Christopher Walken
and Natalie Wood were in a movie
together and there was a lot of
speculation that I don't think anyone
thought that they were sleeping together
necessarily but a lot of people said
that there was like a lot of like they
were like kind of into each other and
there was like you could like tell there
was like a lot of like sexual tension
between them and like a lot of
electricity quote-unquote so I think
Robert Wagner was like kind of pissed
about that and the captain even said
later he's like I heard part of an
argument in which Robert Wagner said to
Christopher Walken are you trying to
[ __ ] my wife quote unquote so apparently
there was a big fight going on on the
boat that night between Robert Wagner
Christopher Walken and it was over her
everyone was drunk nobody denies that so
there's also the testimony which came
out later of some people that were on
another boat that was you know like in
the same area and they said the people
on this boat said they heard somebody a
woman's voice yelling like help me help
me I'm drowning or something like that
so some people have kind of speculated
that one Natalie Wood being afraid of
the water
would not have gotten into the dinghy
like to go to the shore presumably by
herself and also there had been this
whole thing where they were like
fighting and the captain had like caps
that from authorities and he didn't
admit it till many years later so some
people are kind of thinking and in 2011
they came out and announced that even
though Wagner was not a person of
interest before now he was and I don't
even remember your life um if he is he's
in his nineties yeah so he was not
necessarily a person of interest
for even though suspicions have followed
him since then that he maybe I don't
know if he did it on purpose but like I
said everyone was drunk everyone was
fighting maybe if there was some kind of
like you know oh you are having an
affair with Christopher Walken or
whatever
I mean Christopher Walken it doesn't
like I love Christopher Walken I'm not
letting that like [ __ ] color my
perceptions but he doesn't seem to know
what happened he's like look man it's
like yeah we were arguing and stuff but
I just went to bed I don't know what
happened after that so I kind of buy
that but I do kind of think that maybe
the sexual tension between him and
Natalie Wood
I feel like Wagner was maybe getting a
little possessive about it and I don't
know if he meant for anything to happen
but he might have like sounds all
far-fetched to me
it made a push I don't think he meant to
I'm just saying I'm I don't know I don't
know it sounds far-fetched to me people
on another boat hear a woman calling for
help I'm drowning and they don't go help
captain of the ship doesn't [ __ ] jump
in and try to [ __ ] help a woman from
drowning yeah I'll buy it
somebody oh I think dad's all [ __ ] the
surfers later I think it was yeah I
think it was just a normal party and on
the above normal
somehow or another she got up in the
middle of night was gonna walk somewhere
to take a piss or something walking
around the boat slipped and fell in that
[ __ ] couldn't swim she drowned well it
what it looked like it looked like even
at the time when they were you know
presuming that it was like an accident
or whatever it looked like she had tried
to got it to get into the dinghy
the valiant where was the shot deck yeah
or hanging off the side of the boat and
she was trying to get into it to go to
the shore which like I said the captain
was like well I had taken her to the
shore the previous day like in this
dingy because they were out in the yacht
like out in the water and he's like I
don't think she would have done that and
even her sister said that too it's like
she was like really afraid of water so
she wouldn't have like tried to get into
the dinghy by herself she would have
gone
the captain and said hey can you take me
to shore or whatever but actually was
drunk too so I'm not really sure Lee
might have been what she meant they're
saying maybe she went to the dinghy
maybe she was just walking around on the
[ __ ] bow or the stern and walking
around and [ __ ] fell in the water
she's [ __ ] drunk staggering you know
I mean it could be ignite tell me that
it's just an accident right because a
woman falls in the water she can't swim
she drowns that doesn't make it murder
you gotta be able to prove murder don't
you ever be able well they I don't think
they'll ever be in there it's like and
I'm not saying I don't know if Wagner
had anything to do with it I do think
that he had motive to because I do think
that there is sufficient evidence he was
um I think it's unlikely upset about her
and Christopher Walken in there or like
supposed flirtation or whatever it was
and they had had an argument somebody
had thrown a glass or a bottle like at
the restaurant they were at which you
know I can see that I don't know
Hollywood it is kind of a thing to like
it to go from that to like the next day
like I'm gonna push her off the boat
like I said I'm not even if he did do it
I don't think it was on purpose
Hollywood people are wild you know and
so I don't think he'd been that jealous
the fact that [ __ ] walking might have
been trying to [ __ ] chase it down I
don't think I think I'd go for walk in
more than Robert Wagner yeah well even
back in the day but you know there drunk
talking [ __ ] and and they might have not
have been serious when they were talking
about all that true might have been
joking around yeah yeah and I mean I
just I think she got drunk somehow fell
overboard I mean it happens on those
damn pleasure cruises almost big little
ships some of those people I think a
throne but yeah I think it does seem
like oh hey perfect crime yeah but I
think a lot of them I think a lot of
them just drop this ball kind of like
this one is throwing up over the deck so
yeah they're [ __ ] puke and over the
deck and somehow they lose their bout
falled falling between the guard realm
but this one kind of bothers me because
I'm not really like a lot of the other
ones I kind of have an idea even though
I wasn't there like what I think might
have happened this one I'm not really
sure it's like either way could have
been possible it does seem like
it does seem like Robert Wagner acted
kind of sketchy like in the sense that
he didn't really contact anyone right
away even though he'd noticed that she
was missing presumably and some of the
stuff that he said like was contradicted
by the captain later I'd been loaded
yeah but it's like that's the thing when
a lot of people are inebriated at one
time it's like [ __ ] can happen and think
that people don't really remember I
think that would fall on the cap so it's
very possible that she might have like
not gone into the water presumably on
purpose but it's like she might have got
the idea like I said you get drunk you
get stupid ideas it's like she might
have thought hey I'm gonna go to the
shore like [ __ ] going to find the
captain or whatever I'm just gonna get
in the dinghy and go to the shore and
then she did that and then she fell in
captain wasn't watching over him why
they were drinking he doesn't know well
I think this was like late at night this
is like the middle innit yeah he was
like yeah I'm should have been on duty
he should have been but like I'm
watching obviously and like I said the
fact that he didn't come forward till
later I don't know it just seems really
weird to me it's like yes it's very
likely could have been an accident and I
don't want to like accuse anybody of
anything but she's a dangerous place
they're [ __ ] loaded I think she fell
over but it could have been an accident
I mean manslaughter is as far as I'll go
I don't think anybody did anything on
purpose if anything did happen if it
wasn't an accident then I don't think
anyone intended it I just think it was
like a sad circumstance and like I said
I'm not even sure if Robert Wagner is
still alive like in 2011 I think he was
89 he's gotta be dead and they you know
then they came forward and said yeah now
he's a person of interest now that we
have like all this new information but
he kind of like took the fifth and
everything about never get a conviction
but it's kind of like it the the whole
the stigma about it has like followed
him for many years
even though her death was ruled an
accident now in 2011 I should note that
her cause of death was changed to
drowning accidental possibly with other
factors involved or whatever the wording
was
so they actually kind of upgraded it
from accident - accident but maybe not
know I'm saying so I'm not sure how that
all it's gonna go and like I said Robert
Wagner I'm not even sure if he's still
alive at this point because I think he
was 89 and 2011 when they reopened the
case so I'm not really sure and like I
said this is one where I have no idea
because it could seriously go either way
I'm not sure if it was an accident I'm
not sure if it was like I said
manslaughter as far as I go
I'm not saying mostly because I think it
was probably I don't think it was
intentional
I'm saying it's likely she fell
overboard if even if he did push her
overboard it's like I don't think it was
intentional I think everyone was like
fighting going too far to say that
somebody pushed somebody that's not I'm
saying allegedly right if that did
happen then I don't think it was
intentional I think she was that run
around by herself [ __ ] drunk [ __ ]
throwing up over the side fell out
possibly yeah but yeah we'll see all
right so that was our very long probably
it was very long yes it was sure crimes
of old Hollywood hope you guys have
enjoyed it we're probably drunk right
yeah probably
I gotta make [ __ ] yeah you know you make
some pancakes yeah just don't put salt
in there and so sugar you'll do all
right I never did that no I don't think
you ever gonna do all right so hopefully
you guys enjoyed it hopefully you guys
are enjoying our daily updates which we
are going to keep doing at least until
we get tired of doing it or until
Kingdom Come until this [ __ ] [ __ ]
gets sorted out well everyone's not
[ __ ] worried anymore but yeah I hope
you guys are enjoying that so this has
been episode 188 crimes of old Hollywood
and remember if you liked the show
like share subscribe on all your social
media if you'd like to financially
support the show I know you guys are all
kind of probably a little bit doing
financially not so good at the time
because all the [ __ ] is going on but if
you would like to support the show we
would much appreciate it and go to our
patreon page patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a button in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time
donation to keep the show going any
amount is much appreciated and we will
see you next time we see you bye
[Music]
you
[Music]